and
Hello everyone, hello Senpai, welcome to the stream.
We're back at it again with Harvesturder.
Sorry, I'm a slightly bit late, I'm slightly bit late, I had an idle meeting.
Thank you for Griffin, for the 10 gifted, and welcome to member, member, and Iago.
Welcome to member, lord, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah Rock.
Well, I can't read. How are you feeling? My arm is still itchy.
So we're going to be playing kind of, not aggressively.
Now we're going to play not that aggressively.
Are you doing better? Let me check my arm.
There's some patches that are cleared up, but there's some parts that are still pretty bumpy and gross.
And it's, yeah, I have an appointment, I have an appointment with my doctor on Monday, that's the earliest she can see me, I think.
And so we're going to check that out, but watch as like my rash goes away by Monday.
It's LB really, it's always like that, right? It's always like that, it always, it always goes away by the time you get to the appointment.
But yeah, it's been a couple of days now. This morning it was flaring up really badly.
So I had to push, put my like bedsheets and stuff to the wash, so I have no blanket today.
So I've turned on, I've turned on my streaming lights, because sometimes I don't turn them on, but today I'm turning them on, so it's extra warm in the cages and in the basement.
So we're going to continue playing, playing, I don't remember if I have anything else to say, other than I want to just double check the instructions to see if I remember it.
Oh, and I got in the new mouse, the new mouse that Senpai gifted, so now I have a mouse that actually works, and not a mouse that disconnects every moment.
So now I can like move it nice. It fits my hand too.
It fits my hand, so now I've got a nice mouse to play my point and click games.
Okay, let's see, left button to move.
I'm going to start on a puzzle, avoid cliches, crazy logical.
Okay, I think we're good.
Yeah, that was punch.
Double click to open stuff.
Okay, yeah, we're good, we're good, we're good Senpai.
So now we just have to load our last save file.
Which is Senpai, I love you, I think that's the one.
Now you can play a difficult game about climbing.
I think I was too frustrated with that.
Okay, nothing else in here.
Look at my stinking brother.
Give me the paper.
I don't want to talk to him, but he gives so much hints.
He gives so much hints.
And twitched and drew up.
I guess I got my answer.
This is why I hate you.
Hate! Hate!
Hate!
Say what?
Yeah, yeah, I said I hate you.
Yeah, my little brother.
Little brother, hate.
Little sister.
Okay, little brother, hate.
Hate, Trid.
I'm in Sparky's super foamy fire extinguisher.
A new boy in his sleeping soundly.
Hello, mother.
Hello dear, how are you today?
You know those firemen, the funny ones with the color sense.
Looks like they misplaced a bolt of expensive fabric.
Of course, each one of them suspects the other.
Looks like a cat fight is brewing.
Congratulations, hero.
You found Karen after all.
You don't seem proud, mother.
You don't seem proud, yeah.
I warned you not to waste time looking for her.
Am I running out of time?
The blood drive is coming soon.
What does that have to do with anything?
Yeah, why does that have to do with anything?
Thank you, Vincent, for remembering.
Still, I'm glad you found the poor baby.
She says Mr. Potsdam was responsible for what happened to her.
Yeah, I knew it.
I can't believe Potsdam would do something.
I believe her.
Shame on you.
Fuck you.
Imagine accusing your future father-in-law of a thing like that.
Is that how a rain-dryer would behave?
I don't think so.
Why would she lie?
Mr. Eisenheimer, even if he is a child,
molester, a kidnapper, and an attempted murderer
Molester, a kidnapper, and an attempted murderer?
What kind of father-in-law he'll be?
What?!
I just can't wait for the wedding.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What do you mean that does not affect the way he's seen as a father-in-law?
Also, Amy's not related.
I honestly should should should mod serenity, but I don't know how and I'm kind of lazy
I'll do it next time I'll do it next time next time I'll give her the power
I like being able to be sneaky and chat yeah yeah I know now hush hush we're
gaming right now right now love letter
don't forget to put the papers out for Jimmy you know how he gets yeah I know
how he gets cookies my why is my baby sister always asleep anyways let's get
out of here not get out of here I need to save save save save always save a game
remember to save scum Senpai I love you I was good that man I said man I said
you can you can add you can add serenity thank you finish for a gifting 10
oh no it's doing the thing it's doing the thing where it's going through
everyone I tried to fix it I tried to fix it and it didn't fix it at all I tried
to fix it and it didn't fix it at all I'm sorry at least you didn't make it
worse not yet I didn't make it worse yet
you have no idea how hard it is to do variations in like these in these
alerts it's hard it's hard I might force manager to do it for me man I
think you transfer for remembering it sounds cute yeah I because I recorded it
I always sound cute do you not think I sound cute Senpai inventory there we go
where's my paper there it is here you go kid man I want to beat this kid up I
want to beat this kid up I could take on this kid right did you tweet that you're
like
hold on I had my mind on other things Senpai
I had my mind on other things like my arm like icing my arm for example huh okay
just a minute give us a second it's probably I'm gonna confuse about where
everything is there it is
okay okay we're live tweeting this we're live tweeting this Senpai
I'm live have Senpai thank you for the super chat Lord Yaro Yaro that's my
ko ha ko ko ahi thank you for the super sticker it's a rose thank you I want to
have maracas and be like tuxedo mask and bites bites the the rose seductively is
this a horror game yes sure is minor spelling mistake minor smelling mistake
points it out or like almost 20 minutes now oops please join me
ah ha ha stream or mercy and then I gotta add in the room the room give me a
second give me a second I'm I'm a big dummy I'm a big dummy when it comes to
this I always forget I feel like managers should should be mad mad at me a
little more but I think I think mistakes happen I saw some some Senpais call me
Pawn and then I had to look up what Pawn meant because for a while I was like
pom pom way way way pom pom way pom pom and then I had to look at it at that's
pomp isn't it that's not pomp I know what pomp is it's fine strutting every
tweet she's live is that not it no it means like you know you're a little
clumsy apparently means you're you're clumsy so I was like what do you mean
Pawn okay I'm posting it yeah we did it we did yet hey out of here serenity
can't blend anymore I know nope it's it's good so I I it took me a long time to
understand what that was the same thing for like wait wait wait did no one notice
this the security bars fast into the windows are with Philo have flipped
head screws wait okay let's check out our fiance our girlfriend listen here you
little punk did you say hello to your father for me now yes I did thank God
for that at least now I hate you
yeah I know what that crazy little bit said but it's not true I was at home
that night Mrs. Potsdam will that's for me isn't that right Mrs. Potsdam that's
right mr. Potsdam hello Steve care to stay for some pot roast
why me little bitch pot roast mother pot roast isn't for backstabbers for
persecutors I won't share my meat with him why are you covering up for him
Mrs. Potsdam it's the truth that's why and I think you better be going young man
before I call your mother and tell on you those silly willies down at the fire
station are just incensed about losing some decorating
stuff some people yeah maybe they should be more concerned with fire
and less with flame
okay let's go murderer what an odd thing to say
you
each stop mumbling Steve I can't understand you at all you know that's true
kidnapper stop mumbling Steve I can't understand you at all was that a
unique response sure was molester hi what are you getting at
yeah you know you know wait a second
there's two responses I can do this both senpai
that's all I thank you for the super chat crown of time
thanks for the heart my haiku did the others
you asked for oh thank you I saw I just it's hard to kind of
keep up with things I'm bad for that I'm very
but thank you for the the the super chat I'll I'll check it out
I can do both of them I can do both of them Twitter is difficult
yeah it's both you molested Carrie didn't you I wouldn't do that it's illegal not
to mention immoral yeah yeah I can't prove it yet and you better
hope I never can do I look worried oh I hate him
let's try it again I what are you getting at you've been
watching Stephanie undress watching Stephanie what proof do you have now
don't carry on that way that's loose talk there son
do you deny it what do you want
fix the hole all right I want to see you squirm fat man
I already told Stephanie so I want so so maybe I should be like
yeah squirm want to you squirm
I'm squirming squeal for me porky squeal
louder again
senpai squeal now
again
I feel like I have so much power now is this much chibi feels like
I think in Japanese the pig sound is boogie
again
boogie yeah do it in in Japanese now boogie boogie
okay that's enough for now then you're not going to tell Stephanie
or mrs potstown I'll think about it potstown
I'm gonna tell miss potstown I'm gonna tell miss potstown
I get the tattletail
he might want to be extra nice to mr potstown today steve
he was turned down by the logic yes we're having a waiting at mr moine hands
after all moine your hands people
senpai I'm squealing in real life as loud as I can
can you hear it kuhai kuhai yes I can hear it senpai
now do it again thank you for the lead 13 1337
that's lead right wow
people sorry I didn't catch that molester
sorry I didn't catch that oh I can't tattle to her oh
sorry I didn't catch that painting
painting sorry oh my gosh you can't tattle for her
dang it
dang it yeah yeah whatever you were about to look tell me to get out anyways
anyways let's talk to Stephanie
ha ha
is squealing supposed to make you lightheaded or is that love
I had no idea anyways let's take a peek
Eden fix it at all oh no she's sad let's go check on her
she's a sad girl girl let's go
Stephanie I'm glad to see you I feel so alone cooped up in here
my faux mother keeps me up on the latest gossip uh-huh
not like she really wants to talk to me more like she's
feeding me information yes feed us the information for instance
she told me that mr. johnson's Tucker was vandalized uh-huh
that's another weird thing every car I've seen drive by as a Tucker
there were only 31 produced what are the odds of that I've always wanted a
Tucker funny that harvest would be full of them
any idea who scratched the car
do I tell on myself do I tell on myself senpai
don't self-snitch sure sure do it do it you want me to self-snitch myself
not like she's gonna say anything unless
do it okay I'm gonna snitch on myself
I'll snitch on myself don't trust her yeah whatever say first okay
nope I have to do it here not like anyone will believe her that's true
am I am I am I that bitch
I didn't why would you do something like that it's part of the lodge
initiation I see I see look I don't know
what's going on here but getting into the lodge is the best way to find out
by committing vandalism
oh he's mad at me for that huh that guy's a creep
kind of deserved it I mean everyone in town said he deserved it
it's a harmless enough prank by any means necessary
I thought she didn't care for the town's folk that's what I thought too
Stephanie what happened what happened the only town folk
that I care about is Karen and her mother and maybe the shopkeeper because the
shopkeeper kind of seemed sane everyone else is insane
mercy more of a any means necessary kind of go yeah just a little bit
well I guess you'll fit right in won't you
scratching a car is no big deal getting out of this mess is
sorry when you put it that way I guess I was she seemed reason
what a good good girl someone stole some fabric from them
and they're up in arms about it
do I also snitch on myself again
why would anyone steal a bolt of fabric wow
hmm should I do it yeah that was me too yeah that was me too
another harmless prank and how many more harmless pranks will you be pulling
however many it takes to get in Stephanie if I have to use them to escape
then I will are you using them or are they using you
it's just a bolt of cloth you've turned the firemen against each other
they think one of their own stole it would you rather stay here
I've heard that harvest is lovely in the fall when the leaves turn orange and
oh no our first couple bickering all right all right you have a point
is it true you found Karen yep she did yeah just in time too he molested her
and buried her he couldn't bring himself to kill her out light so he just decided
to stick her in the ground and let fate take its course who would do that to a
helpless child she says it was mr potstown and I believe her
and all this time I've been under the same roof with that
that thing watching me take it easy okay so at least he'll be coming to take him
away won't they no
oh Stephanie you mean
I can thank you well come back and visit share Stephanie
we would never bicker like that call hi don't worry oh don't worry
I have developed many many problem-solving skills
and many many many problem-solving skills and
argument mitigations and stuff so if we ever bicker senpai
don't worry about it
yeah I I can I I specialize in conflict conflict uh resolutions yeah yeah
yeah
so don't worry senpai I have it all covered don't be scared now
thank you for the memba sliceba
don't worry about anything I have everything covered
I promise nothing can go wrong
hello Steve hello Steve do you want to buy anything today yeah
just point to whatever naughty fellas like deputy lumas aside
I think every man should cultivate an interest in girly magazine
if it'll keep them out of the field of interior design
those firemen Betsy you should hear them carrying on
accusing each other of being thieves a bolt of cloth disappears you'd think it
was the end of the world
am I supposed to avoid it if they find that bolt of cloth on me damn
do I still have it note chair of checkbook
autograph vitamins tampons fire axe I still have it I still have it
I still have it I still have it I still have it so we're gonna have to save
before we go that we do anything again
look at those can I get anything can a soup or rat poisoning
mm robust kaffee kaffee
okay we're good you need to give it to the lodge
I probably do actually I probably do need to give it to the lodge
where's the lodge there it is the lodge
exquisite class exquisite class should trigger quite a bit of
dissension amongst our gallant firefighters
still that is not your concern your next assignment is to break into the
tonsorial establishment of mr. pastorelli and abscond with his prized
barber's pole
all right I've got to a scond the barber Paul
speaking of exquisite any words of the day oh yes I did think of a word of the
day are you ready are you ready senpai for the word of the day
the word of the day is lenticular
lenticular
is the printing process where they make you know if you like tilt the little
thing it's got the little ridges
where you twist you you uh
tilt it and then it like changes pictures and stuff
it's like an illusion thing yes
they can call them like a bunch of stuff yeah
spell it out I think everyone's spelling it out in chat quite well
l-e-n-t-i-c-u-l-a-r
that is today's word of the day
there's also the lenticular lenses and other different things so you're all
good
keep those in mind keep those in mind when you see when you see those
bookmarks where they change pictures you'd be like oh wow this is a lenticular
printing style
what do you think senpai is that a good word of the day
it took me a while to think of something
it took me a while to think of something but I wanted to I wanted to be like
yes here's a word or something that you might not know what it's called
but now you know
thank you for the $2 super chat go hi I lost my job I was laid off I need a hug
damn
well um
good luck senpai
I'm sorry I don't know what to say other than like I'm sorry for for your loss
for your loss I hope that it leads you to a better to find a better job
with um
blackjack
and girlies
losing a job always sucks and I am no stranger to that
I'm no stranger to that I've lost
all of my jobs not not because of like any any any reason of my own other than like
other than like oh you know um my job my job like shut down or it was it was um
or they they they hired overseas uh that one sucks and and like oh it's just the end of
my um my internship so it's like oh yeah that happens right you know so there's nothing
so so it's I'm not a stranger to loss jobs or anything but you know look positively to the
future and be like yeah I'll just get another one that's better maybe I'll have more free time
and hone my craft
mysterious fire mysterious fire no nothing burned just you know they've all been quite uh
amic amicable yeah yeah my all my jobs have been like kind of like amicable
believing
um
without losing your job you wouldn't be able to lock us in cages
yeah now I have better ways of locking senpai in cages
let's see my last job was
my last job was what do you call it real estate
it was real estate
yeah scouting out locations and all those empty houses
did you find the mystical free real estate no I did not
was it fun sort of it was fun I learned a lot
I learned a lot but I definitely
wouldn't do it again oh maybe I would or maybe I would you know if the opportunity arises I
probably would do it again if like if for some reason if for some reason I cannot make a living
here or I'm not working hard enough or something I'll probably take another additional job maybe in
real estate again I learned how bad the housing market is yes I learned and I learned there are
so many people who are ridiculously rich like there's some processes where when in real estate
you know you're just kind of like they're like I want to play pay the whole the whole thing now
I'm like technically we can't sell you this without you know without some more papers
and then they go and then they go but I want to pay the whole thing right now in cash and I go
that's nice we can't do that
a full buyout yeah yeah yeah but they wanted to do in cash and that's not
it's really a lot of the pay paperwork would be way more complex than it is
and like the house that they wanted to buy was was a big house
was a big house can I say it can I say the cost of the house
anyways it's a big house it was uh
let's say it was over one million
it was a big house
and they were like I want to pay in cash and I was like
um
I can't do that I can't do that
do you get a cut of it no
no because I didn't sell to them
what exactly is wrong with paying in cash is because we need the paperwork and the paperwork
usually requires like a lot more steps than just paying out full in full cash right because you
have property and then you have the lawyer stuff and then you have bank notes and stuff and of
course you need like a line of credit blah blah blah blah blah it's a lot to buy a house
it's a lot to buy a house and it's like and title BS and then you have to like transfer transfer
titles and stuff the implication of paying on cash is that you don't do paperwork but the thing is
that like if I get paid in all cash it would be like you know people will start suspecting something
and then it will go into a whole investigation and that's another whole load of like paperwork
yeah
oh sorry I missed the two super chats oh I need to feed me herself now
I'll throw you a bone and can I stay out of the k can I stay in the cage for free now
I thought who's been paying rent should I have been charging rent for these cages
who's charging rent
the landlord me no wrong it's me
damn found out half of half of the uh half of the senpais are mysteriously gone next day
watch
okay I guess I guess if it's strongy if it's strongy then I guess that's okay
I guess it's okay
yeah strongy has been charging rent to fund VLR success
but I'm pretty sure I didn't I didn't charge rent that's why I've been saying that I'm so nice to you
no I've been paying I've been so nice to you I've been housing all my senpais in this cage
then sometimes
although if it is strongy then um I guess
I guess that it is what it is
but I saved up for a whole year to afford this one square foot cage
but yeah um gosh well I've been yapping right anyways um
it seems highly illegal and I don't want to like you know I don't want to be investigated for
for I don't know assisting a crime or something you know what I'm saying
senpai I don't want to I don't want to leave a trail I already know how to not leave a trail so
um why would I why would I accept one million cash you know
so yeah I was like okay well here's the steps you need to take before buying the house
and you know that's what I did that's what I did I uh I gave them a list of what they needed to do
before they they could buy the house and then they never bought the house
and besides one more thing one more thing and uh one more thing
we don't know if the cash is real or not it could be printed printed like you know fakes
so
yeah like you you never know right that's why you gotta be like okay well in cash
that's kind of suspect uh so I want to go through the regular avenues for this house
so I was like no no no no no no no now
mercy do your best colombo impression that was my best colombo impression
yeah I have to follow the rules the housing market is like there's a lot of rules for housing
and stuff so if I don't follow all of them I get in trouble
I get in trouble otherwise but then the rules
then the rules you can't you can't you know
you can't really just buy a house I don't know where it is a little bit of work maybe
the fastest you can do is probably a day
but you gotta have to yeah you have you have to um
but then I'd have to work my ass off I have to work my ass off to get all the paperwork done
to do like in a day so that's that's like um
it is how it is anyways sorry me starting to think about the housing market and I'm like
man I want my own place and then I look at the places that like it gets sold and I'm like oh
I do want my own place though I do want my own place eventually so
I'm willing I'll be happy to do my own paperwork for that
oh sorry give me a second step by
I'm gonna BRB I'm gonna need I'm gonna need to go get an ice pack again to put to ice my arm
because it's flaring up again
I'll be right back okay
so
okay
okay sorry about that I don't know you'll you'll you might occasionally hear
you're the ice pack so I'm sorry about that's that's some pie it's just been flaring up so
I'm like dang it okay uh thank you for the one dollar super chat all around and thank you for
the two dollar super chat I love that chocolate see cca cca volts
but yeah you can hear you can probably that's the ice pack if you can see hear it it's already
excuse me it's already melting because of how how like how much heat is emitting from this rash
how's the arm doing it's there's some spots that I've healed up completely but then there's the
spots that haven't healed up or pretty like okay let's continue
should I say I've had enough of this or I'm gonna open a salon sarge
senpai
thank you we love you thank you boy we love you senpai not senpai gosh
wow I have senpai brain rot I always think of you all we love you kaha even if you're all
bumping red it's just my right arm it's just my right arm
it's just my right arm
I now do it thinking of opening a salon sarge
lack of respect for authority a fine trait for member of the older yes I am
I hope you succeed in your task wow you really like that huh
steal the bomb and bring it back to me at that point I shall give you your final task
so uh I'm gonna save now and I'm gonna see if I can do conflict resolution
if I'm as good as I I claim to be
dang it I'm gonna do this now save game
oh wait no no no no no yeah yeah you know what let's let's do this senpai I love you here
the ai chat summary is calling you quorum why is it calling me quorum
what the heck is quorum
am I not allowed to be here police station
and
boy the way you keep pestering me you think you were feeling guilty about something
are you I'm nowhere near solving the Tucker case and now I have to deal with a bunch of
firemen throwing a hissy fit over some stolen cloth can you imagine what the heck is going on around
here
bye anytime Steve why does he say it like that sorry I don't feel up right now
talking that is
bye anytime kiddo
what the heck is a quorum
anyways let's go to the tv station hopefully it's on fire already
oh no wait actually let's go to the the diner Edna are you okay
bye bye
I can't talk now the dishes are stacked up in back and I better take advantage of the lull
I feel terrible about what happened at the fire station those firemen helped me decorate my diner
I can't believe one of them stole that cloth from the others it must have been someone else don't you think
hmm do I save this place or are they gonna kill me
curious
it's from an old meme
I only know the the lightest one which is that kid a cute little kid going
and yeah I can't talk now proceeds to have an entire conversation this is point and click games
and gentlemen I present you
the latest was that yeah wait is that not that's probably a few years old now right
well I'm gonna go in and see if it's on fire yet
it's not on fire
I really like that one though I always remember I like anytime I see corn I just think of that
that kid going going corn is my favorite thing
wait can I go to the school and peep on them yet
not this guy again seeing you here again one would think you'd never graduated
nostalgia is a waste of time big guy you need to move forward and if you ask me the
logic lies firmly in that direction Mr. Johnson says one of my pupils scratched his priceless
Tucker I must say I was relieved when I learned he had no evidence pointing to one of my kids
if he had some lucky boy or girl would have been in for some quality time
say congratulations on finding Karen Fitzpatrick don't know how you did it but if I were still
publishing the Sentinel you can bet I'd run a full profile on you
drop in again soon adult education is a wonderful thing as is adult quality time
adult quality time huh can I open this yet the door is locked
I want I want to break in I got the key what time do I even know what time okay
okay oh man which which door is it I can't remember which door it was the utility closet
this one that one that one that one that one dang it maybe I have to go at night
or whatever time he said before
we spend a lot of quality time together right senpai
the meat plant
let's go talk now Steve I've got to hose out some entrails
okay bye don't be such a stranger Steve and my best year yeah okay okay okay yeah I know the meat
plant oh what about the meat
let's check out the barbershop pastor ellies
mr pastor ellie doesn't respond non-understanding
lush think about taking some of that siding off my hand son I'll cut you a nice price on it
all right I tell you the only thing worse in a fire station full of sissy's is a fire station
full of pigs you see they're all accusing each other of stealing some thank you for joining
memba good boy or whoever said fight and fire with fire be happy and harvest
because we got a fire station full of flamers is that what they used to call people back then
nice to see you again Steve
I can't talk now son I'm busy with this game I can't talk proceeds to probably talk later
I can't talk okay hold on I'm checking some things
any time
tight slots cruise I have anything for that
man honky camera my notes sheriff if you think you're gonna keep going no no no
jim bob who was in high school star picture 26 years ago hangs his aging leather jacket here
when he comes in for a trim
can we take pictures I think we're supposed to take pictures when we keep on when we keep on the uh
principal
post office
hi sorry son no time to talk neither rain nor sleep nor snow nor hell shall keep the mail
from his pointed rounds okay bye next time you post don't forget the zip code I'm expecting
him to send things on fire set things on fire that's some very specific information about the
cult rack right hmm maybe we should talk to mom again
oh let's save again save here I I feel like I need to be doing something right
there's my dad again what oh it's you son I told you not to come in here it's too risky I need
some meat and Pat won't give me any without your sign permission good old dependable Pat
here son here's my signal now go son okay bye
I guess that's the only thing we have to do to interact with there
go now son
mom hello dear
bye don't forget to
I know Jimmy Jimmy needs his paper how many papers can I collect
uh shit at the steal it right sheriff's checkbook
woof see I want the broom closet key I don't know where to use the broom closet key though
I really want I really want to really want to bother him with it cemetery oops
yeah we found her in there I think that might be the only thing
hmm we always have to look around and point and clicks
shady oaks mortuary
can I get this glue
you can't I was only going indeed secure I'm afraid that's not good
something significant
something significant huh I played Stanley terrible and then it doesn't do anything well
oh hold on okay hold on
my ice pack is condensating right now
one go down let's check out the wayward hotel
anything I can look at oh what's this name of ledger's the last being jenith and a
Ryan clip checked in monday I'm taking that
pta's bake sale Friday
okay
reflections may make the lobby seem spacious more spacious than it actually is
yeah man we really have nothing to say to each other okay bye I'd say it's been a pleasure
okay we got that
fireholes mail box
newspaper building I think that's all I needed from the newspaper building was
maybe I can use the shovel on there
buried in the ash debris you spot a few hidden remains
it's a flyer for the harvest bake sale
it says a postal worker's button and it looks like it was ripped from the cloth
oh oh
oh let me check these stuff huh aren't flyer
button
uh check books I got my my thing back so that's cool
we got some stuff now what do we do with that stuff I want to go into fire station
okay probably nothing what if I go to that guy that creepy creepy guy
sorry Steve too tired to talk right now I just gave the tucker a two look the
tucker has the air scratch on it bye bye now I'm going to your house
everyone's got pitchforks
anything I can grab here flashlight rubber mallet lights
canister no okay
be more specific than creepy guy they're all kind of creepy huh
okay hold on brb my ice pack is leaking it's leaking
so
This is the end of this video.
Thank you for watching.
I hope you enjoyed this video.
See you next time.
Music playing.
Sorry about that Senpai.
Sorry about that.
I
had to take
an idle meeting
while doing that too.
I uh,
what's the word? I went
I decided to just put the
ice pack back in the freezer
since it was melting really fast too.
Hahahaha
Did you hit, did you record it?
Wait what?
Why would I record that?
Hahahaha
Um
Children look stunned
and zombified.
Hahahaha
Senpai
Check your live tag, you won't be disappointed.
I'll do that after stream. Thank you.
Hahahaha
Okay
Uh
What?
Hahahaha
Uh
Closet?
Can I write down closet?
Hahahaha
Uh closet?
Can I write down closet?
Hahahaha
We don't practice corporal punishment here.
I've never believed in that old adage.
Spare the rod and spoil the child.
A rod is too thin.
But a baseball bat
That bridges the generation gap quite nicely.
Okay
Okay, okay.
Stay quick
Not again
Can I, can I skip it? There we go.
Bye bye
Can I, can I grab the bat?
No
I feel like I'm supposed to do something before night time.
I wonder how to do that.
The door's locked.
Is this it?
No
Oof.
Didn't mean to do that.
This has to be the closet, right?
Try the pulse badge?
I feel like I was supposed to use the blackmail him but I uh...
My button
Why I lost that months ago, where did you find it?
Funny thing that
I found it in the ashes
At the newspaper building
What are you implying?
That I had something to do with setting the fire?
Preposterous.
Why a hundred people must have visited that site since the fire?
But none of them had buttons like this.
You just try showing that button to Sheriff.
Oh yeah?
Button
Wait, can I see that again? Okay
Bye
Do I still have the button?
Okay
Do I go to the officer then?
I don't know
Can I use the screwdriver?
Damn it
Well that didn't work
Okay, that didn't work so
What else do we have?
A wrench
Okay, well that didn't work
Electrical tape for the wire
Damn it
Wait, where did it go? Did I put it back in myself?
Yeah, I did
Well that didn't work
Oh wait
Oh man
Well that didn't work
Maybe I can set off the alarm here
Oops, didn't mean that one
Okay
No
Maybe I should do this at night time
Night time, night time
Can I really not go on the fire station?
Maybe I can do it at night time
How do we skip time?
Yeah, I don't know how, I feel like I need to do something
Before
Is this the note?
Yeah
Yeah, this is the last guy
who came in
Okay
Well that didn't work
Can I take a picture of that?
Picture?
A camera, there it is
Okay
Well that didn't work
Oh man, well that didn't work
Ooh, lightning
Lightning
What if I go?
Just in case
Vampire
What if I go?
Where is the law?
I'll tell Ledger, there you go
Give me this
Can I steal stuff?
I want this
Come on
I want to get in here
Can I?
That is the broom closet, right?
It looks like that is the broom closet
so
I have to get there somehow
when he's not there
Mercy mutton
not have her tea tonight
because she's thirsty to get in that closet
I do have my tea
I do have my tea senpai
Okay, the hint is that
when you get to the fire station
I don't think we can go to the fire station
unless it's night time
Maybe I'll go back to the lodge again
and be like, what's up?
I've had enough of this, I'm no thief
Of course I am
Okay, what am I doing with the pole?
No?
Okay, so I have to steal that pole
What flavor is my tea?
Today's tea is, I wrote it down
I wrote it down senpai
Today's tea is
raspberry pomegranate
green tea
Doesn't that sound nice senpai?
Maybe I should make copies
I remember seeing like, oh you can make
three copies here, right?
Maybe I can copy all of the stuff
hotel ledger
Oh man, well that didn't work
No?
My sign meet permission?
Oh man
The note?
I got a copy of the note
What about this?
A copy of that?
I photocopied the badge?
Probably not
What about the burnt flyer?
Damn it, damn it
I'll copy of this guy?
Oh man
Maybe I can confront the officer now?
Oh no
But I want the building to
burn down
Oh, let's save
Or maybe not, save game
Senpai
Okay, I'm going to go in here
and see if there's anything else though
Vital clue in the
mysterious jolly fat man
murder spree
dartboard
What is that?
No, I don't know what that is
beer can
binoculars, fuzzy bear, wielding
a chainsaw
exhaust
No
More unsolved cases
Get the diner probably
Wait, maybe I can go like
fire
Nevermind
Door is locked
Can I just break in
to this again?
Anything else?
No
Probably at the
Oh, if he's at the diner, maybe
Oh no, he's not moved yet
I
I keep on clicking the wrong
thing
I was going to say Senpai again because I'm
stupid, he's not here either, what the fuck is he?
I can't talk now
Bye
Wait, what was that?
Okay
Not here
Where'd he go?
The hell?
He's here, he's getting paid off
No
This is the worst part about point and clicks
Sometimes you know what to do, but you
don't know how to do them
Maybe I can blackmail
the post office man again
Maybe
Hi
Guess what I am
Hmm
What about the miso guy? The miso guy
will kill me, we already know that, he just
He'll kill me at any moment
Wait
What if I
Break
No
Okay, it's stuck to the thingy
It's here
Oh wait, there's
some lights here
Okay, I have to use
the light later
Looks like
Your tongue is pretty long, Koi
La la la la la
No more
to taste you with
right here
What does that tongue do?
It tastes, it has
a bunch of
areas that
Senpai
That has a
lot of taste buds in a bunch of places
and then you can taste
lots of food, yeah, thank you
for the 5
5 Super Chat
Roses I read, I'm licking
my lips, your yandere, boo
tea is big, it will
cause an eclipse
You didn't rhyme
big Senpai
You didn't rhyme big
Try again
What the
Oh
Phew, I just thought
something was happening, I was like okay
Oh
Shit, don't forget to put
Yeah, yeah, I know
Did I check the mail?
Hmm
Is he still here?
Oh my gosh, he's still freaking
here, can I just
It's so weird, cause like
I'm trying to find the
sheriff and he's not around
He's not around, what the
heck did I, did I mess something up?
Yeah, I checked the cafe already
Look, look, look, look
Eat them, eat them
Eat them
See, he's not here
Where'd he go?
See, he's not there
He's not there
Howdy
And not at the fire station
We can't get into the fire station
This is the part of point and click
cause I don't like where I'm just like
okay, we have to guess
and do dumb things now
He like, we can't get in
I think we can only get in
when it's like night out
Can you give your brother the autograph photo?
I tried last time
and he's like, I don't care
He's literally like, I don't care
Where is it?
Oh, there it is
See, he doesn't care
Can you still pull the fire?
That's what I tried to do
but I wasn't able to do it
Okay, well I guess I'll check
the wasp lady
Military guy, okay
Okay, let's do some
some really dumb stuff
That pie, let's do some really dumb stuff
No, we start handing things
We start handing things over
Okay, well that's nice
Do you want anything about this button?
A triviality
Hotel ledger?
Um
Do you want some tampons?
No tampons
Vitamins
Moon logic time, right?
cough medicine
aspirin
Anything?
A pen?
Need a pen?
Need
a
A bake sale?
No
What about the
checkbook?
Okay, what about um
I don't, it's key
No?
I feel like some of these are like useless
Okay, well bye
Bye now
Wait, there's like a
I wonder if I can use the manhole cover for this
Damn it
Damn it, okay, maybe not, jeez
There's nothing else to do at the lodge?
No
He just talks about the cloth
And that's it
We must point and click further
Further
What if I give you this?
What does that sheriff told you?
The sheriff said calm down
No
I
I didn't soft lock myself, right?
We didn't soft lock ourselves, right?
The diner?
Oops
That's the TV station, my bad
Oh, that's another Tucker, you're right
There, oh my gosh, he's right
There's like a ton of Tucker's
I always like those like blue stuff
I can't talk
Bye
Oh, I'm supposed to give the cloth
Wait, I was
Drawer on the left, hold on
I was supposed to give the cloth to him
I thought he already
You know what, never mind
Locked door
What's this?
Oh
I didn't know
Alright, is the cloth still in your inventory?
No, I don't think so, I think he took it
I think he took it
Yeah, he took it
Strawny asked if I'll keep streaming
for another hour
Likely
I got a screwdriver, yeah
Thank you for the hand
Thank you for the hand senpai
That was hard to see
Oh
Okay, well, it's night time
It's night time, yay
Finally, progress
We're gonna break into the fire station
Oh, shit
He's dead
Do I have the cloth?
Can I fix it?
Can I fix this?
No
I don't have the cloth anymore, I can't fix this
I can't fix it
Let's
Meat plant
Oh, yeah
Okay, time
I did the boba shop
Barber shop is closed
Save
Yeah
Okay
We break in
with the wrench
No
I must have put that in
That's not how exactly a professional would break in
What do you mean?
What do you mean that's not how a professional would break in?
Are you serious?
Damn
Except for the occasional hairball coughs
Can I
Unscrew this
Yay, no
No, I got caught
I got caught
Oh, no
Okay, okay
Well, I'm gonna lull the game again
Good thing I saved
We saved scum in this house
Or in this basement
Not the law
Okay, first I put electric tape
On the door
And I break in
So that it doesn't arouse suspicion
Senpai
Thank you for the five
I give you affection
Can I come out of the cage for a little bit now?
Maybe I have to turn
Okay
Oh
I got it
Yeah
I did it
School time now, hopefully
I want to go to the school
I'm breaking into the broom closet
Let me in
Why do you sleep in jeans?
I want to pee, yeah, I want to pee
But also, why does this man sleep in jeans?
What do people want from me?
I want to pee
I don't think so
The most I sleep in
Is like
My t-shirts
I have a bunch of sleeping t-shirts
On colder days though
On really cold days
I wear like, fleece jammies
What the hell is this?
Senpai
What to say?
Please click the left button
Wait what?
Hold on
I need a full screen this
What does this say?
What the fuck does this say?
Excuse me Senpai
Click
Second disc time
What do you mean second disc?
What does this say? Hold on
Press control
F4 and click left mouse button
Control
F4
Okay
Did it work?
Hello?
Did I mess up Senpai?
I don't have a second disc
I bought this on Steam
I bought on Steam
There's no second disc
Senpai save me
Save me
Whoa
Wait it worked
We're saved Senpai
Yeah
I don't know how I did it
I just kept doing it
Like I was told
Save game
It worked eventually
We bought those
We um
Wait is it still saying it at the bottom?
Wait the bottom still says
Save game
It's okay we'll just leave it there
Now we'll just leave it there
I'm not gonna risk anything
Leave me alone
Bye
Good finally
Okay you know what never mind
We might have to close it
Yeah we might have to close it
Look it's stuck now Senpai
It's stuck now
Did I save? I saved
Oh wait no no no
I fixed it I hit exit again
We're good
Did you hear what happened at the barber shop?
Someone broke into Pastorelli's salon
and took his antique barber's pole
The next morning Pastorelli
touched some live wires that the thief left lying around
and was electrocuted
Well that darn foreigner got what he deserved
if you ask me
coming into a nice little town like harvest
and stealing business
Heavens if a bow and scissors
were good enough for your father
I don't see why decent working folk
need a fancy wop styling their hair
That's how it goes
First you get a sissy trim then bang
You're a communist
Isn't it exciting Steve?
Five days and twelve hundred cookies later
the bake sale is already here
Where does the time fly?
Those one thousand
two hundred cookies
Senpai
Oh about twenty
the rest were stale
but the effort wasn't wasted it's for a good cause
Will you be at the school tonight?
Wouldn't miss it
That's nice dear
It's good to be open to new experiences
Oh my gosh
No wonder your hair is terrible ma'am
That was definitely
a Facebook mom type of comment
Yeah
Oh my gosh
I would just like to tell
everyone I do not
believe and
reflect on this opinion
Anyways thank you for the super chat
A lot of these red
scissors are sharp this yandere
has kidnapped me and stolen my heart
There it rhymes
Yep that one rhymes good job good pat
Good good job
Good job
It's good to be
open to new experiences
at the conservative wife
Yeah
And disclaimer this game
was made a long time ago
and it was
a protest
against censorship
So therefore there is going to be some things
that are very you know
controversial
But
please know that I do not reflect
the opinions in these games
What's the good cause
The air
shock their systems gets them
every time
What
Okay bye
I guess
Yeah that's fine cookies
cookies
newborn baby
I guess that's it huh
Dang city folks
that makes
Empire
Okay
I have the paper
I don't have the paper
Wait no I do have the paper why didn't
I see it
I have the paper
Wow I just didn't see it here you go
kid
Man I hate this kid what do you want
Yeah whatever kid
Okay let's get out of here
Okay first mission
You gotta bot stem's residence
Now I haven't seen him
Yeah yeah I get it
I killed a person
I don't know
Was there a way I could
have saved him some pie
Hello dear
Yes please
The bake sale is tonight
Seven o'clock at the school
Lots of cookies and yards of floss
Hope to see you there
Guards of floss okay bye
Give my regards to your parents
Only indirectly
Why did I do that
I'm so sad
He can't be saved
That's okay
I don't know
I see my mother throwing out whole batches
of cookies like an automaton
getting rid of its surplus product
My so called mother has been baking
cookies all week and then
throwing them out better that
than getting rid of us
Wait around long enough
I have a feeling they'll get to it
I don't know if you heard or not
but Mr. Pastor Ali the barber
He's dead
Looks like somebody stole
a barber's pole from him
Then left the exposed electrical wires
and some water on the floor
Pastor Ali walked in flipped on the lights
and
No anything about that
No
Okay fine I didn't mean to kill him
I just wanted the pole for the initiation
Fuck it, fuck it we did this
That was our bed
Like a man died
I didn't know
I forgot about the live wires
and the water
That doesn't change the fact that you killed him
This initiation killed him
It was just an accident
It was just like some time
where I
Don't you see
I'm beginning to think that the lodge
poisons everything it touches
Harvest
I didn't create this situation
Are you sure
No
But however it started
I'm gonna see it through to the end
Vandalism theft
Manslaughter
What's next Steve, murder
Second
I know in the beginning I suggested you might check out the lodge
I was more worried about getting out of here
than anything else
But now that I know you
I'm worried about you too
I'm fine
I'm not fine
Come back and visit me soon
You can't just ask that after
After doing that to me
You can't just ask that
I know I understand
Sometimes sometimes
You know
Sometimes sometimes just force my hand sometimes
And then I just have to
I just have to
Yeah
I know it happens to the best of us
I didn't mean it though
I didn't mean it
Sometimes Senpai just walks into my knife
And my scissors
And my bat
And my
And the barrel
The bone saw was me though
But yeah
You sometimes just walk into all of them
And here it is
The object dog
The guard
Imported Phoenician glass
And Italian dreams
Italian dreams
An unfortunate side effect
That pastorelli was
electrocuted because
You left live wires
In a puddle
I didn't know there was a puddle
The stations of worldliness say
Say love you
Oh you can say it man it was electrocuted
Pastorelli's own incompetence
Caused his unfortunate
Accent
Maybe his incompetence
I had
You left live electrical wires
Hanging in the water
On the floor
Cross wired the alarm system
To the sprinklers
He'd be live today
Of course
You only wanted the pole
But that hardly matters now
But he turned on the light
What?
What do we have to do?
No not the nice lady
And her daughter's diner
Not the diner everybody eats
There
Not the French
They're not French
Are they?
They're not French are they?
Oh no oh no
Does that mean we have to fry
That means French
French Canadian
Oui oui
Ah sacre ble
And
Ah
Ah whatever
That's no minor prank
So close
And yet so far
What a pity
Tonight
The big sale
What do you mean docks
That was on her debut
When sacrifice will be
The order of the day
What?
Okay repeat this
Okay pastor only took a big spill
A permanent one
Alright any suggestions?
So
You know
He just went
Okay I gotta move the window
Up a little bit I can't get out of here
Without it moved
There it is
Um
I have to set fire
To that nice ladies
Diner
Bye bye
I can't talk now
The dishes are stacked up in back
And I better take advantage of the lull
I've whipped up a huge batch of brownies
For the PTA bake sale tonight
I just wish I could do more
To help out those poor bums
How will this sale help bums?
Most of the bums that die in harvest
Lack the money for a good Christian burial
The proceeds from this sale
Will help Mr Moynihan provide them
With proper burial services
Doesn't it strike you as funny
That so many wanderers die in harvest?
No
Strikes me as sad
You have an odd sense of humor Steve
Mr. Pastorelli was electrocuted
He's dead
It looks like some thief wanted
His barber's pole but didn't think of the consequences
Yeah
That's what the guy had to do
Maybe whoever it was really needed
That barber's pole bad
There's no excuse for hurting someone else
Even if Pastorelli were alive
Now his heart would be broken
And what's a little profit compared to that?
The most normal
These are the
These characters
Are the sense of
Is the moral reasoning
And I have to burn down
Their
Their precious home
I mean like this was her
Her memento from her
From the husband that went away
Ugh
I feel bad
But I'm not gonna stop
I'm not gonna stop
Ugh
I feel bad
I feel like really bad
But I'm not gonna stop
Ugh
Okay
Hello?
Yes
I did it
Got him! Yeah!
We did it!
Woohoo!
You're busted!
What will people think?
Yeah
He's a smiley bear
But we should give him a token of our
Appreciation for his silence
Here Stephen, take this baseball bat
You'll find it quite useful
Alright
Maybe I could use a good solid bat
Yeah boy
Take the bat
And we'll take the photo
However will I keep the children in line now
I have a spare I can bring in tomorrow
Unless you prefer a chainsaw this time
I'll talk to Mrs. Phelps
Can I do it again?
Okay
Well that didn't work
A chainsaw?
Oh strongy!
I feel so terrible
That's okay
Start using the bat
On what?
Okay
Mama AP
Okay mama can
Can sleep
Welcome Raiders
Welcome to the stream
Hello hello hello
I am one of mama's
Five
Daughters
You don't say the t's when you're
In squats
And today
I am committing crimes
Not real crimes
Game crimes
We are currently playing
Harvester
It's a game from
Senpai
When was this game made?
Anyways
It was a
Oh
Controversial game
1996 yeah yeah yeah yeah
It's a pretty old game
My breasts huh
Hope to see you at the back sale tonight
When I went to get my hair trimmed this morning
Imagine my surprise
When I learned that the barbershop
Had been burglarized
And worse that Mr.
Pastor really had been electrocuted
Harvest mourns the loss
Of an irreplaceable citizen
All of us will feel the loss
Only with the passage of time
Drop in again soon
If you weren't
If you weren't a diddler
Senpai
Thank you so much secret for a gifting
A memba
If you weren't
If you weren't a diddler
That would have been some like
Okay thing to say you know
You know
Well now I have a bat
Oh right
Yes of course
Well that kid's gone
But
We don't practice
That bridge is the
Oh dear
Wait I thought she gave me her bat
Now she has a bat again
Okay bye
Bye
So how do I use this
Do I just go
Can I kill him
Bye
I didn't save
I was the last time I saved
In cold blood I can
Well you know
It's fine
What
This is nip
Too late for that boy
Ain't it sergeant
Indeed it is
Sheriff
Answers may only be found
In the lodge
And you must be alive
To see them
Oh
Oh okay
Bye
Bye me
Oh
Well that was my bad
Let's not do that again
My bad
Load game
Well when did I
When did I
When did I save
All the way back here we're fine
I need my paper
Okay
Blah blah blah bye
Mom
Yeah yeah yeah
I have some things to do
What is the good cause
Hey goodbye
Don't forget to put
There we go we're kinda back
It's not too bad it's just the start of the day
And then we go here
And then we open our inventory
And then we give
See how easy it is
Things are so much better between us
When you remember the paper in the morning
Let's keep them that way
Have you tried flirting with mommy yet?
Yep I did
And then
I was like so is anything gonna happen
And then nothing happened so now I'm sad
That nothing happened but at the same time
A little relieved you know
I can't believe that if I break into a place
Then
Then I get a kiss on the forehead
And a tucked in good night
And like a death sentence for attacking someone
I can't believe it
I'm just like okay
Well
Go back to the Potsdam's residence
That was my bad
Is this a visual novel? No
It's a point
Look at us we're pointing
And we're clicking
There it is
Bye bye
I hate this man's
Hello dear
Yeah
She's upstairs
The bake sale is to
Okay bye bake sales tonight
Okay got it
Yeah
Yeah I pointed and clicked too hard
Okay we're going in here
Maybe Stephanie knows what to do with the tampons
I remember it says maybe Stephanie knows what to do with the tampons
Tampons
Are you making some kind of point?
No
I'm fine
Yep
I didn't mean to kill him my bad
I'm fine
Bye sorry
I'm skipping through the text because we already got it
Don't forget to save this time yes
Gotta save
Save
Where's the second disc
Yeah we gotta get
A bat
Oh yeah and we gotta go to the lodge
Hi
Yeah you're imported glass
Blah blah blah blah
That's no minor
Prank
Okay
I guess I have to do it
The game will be over
I think I went to
Edna's diner
And she's like the voice of reason in this game
Hi Mr. Bake Sale
Mr. Pastorelli was electrocuted
He's dead
It looks like some thief wanted his
Barbers pole but didn't think of the consequences
Could you hit the lodge guy with the bat?
Maybe whoever it was really needed that
Barbers pole bat
That's no excuse for hurting someone else
Even if Pastorelli were alive now
His heart would be broken
We'll consider that
Hi
Or the sheriff
We'll consider those possibilities
Soon
Now
We can go spy on them
Hihi
Use the key
Oh man
Okay
We got it
Can I save?
Yeah
We'll save here
And then
Say cheese
Yeah
Blasted
What will people think?
Yeah
You'll find it quite useful
Should we
I wonder if it's like
I think the photo is worth more than that
Should we do that? Should we do like
There's more than that
Let's just see
I'll take the fricking bat
Whatever I'll take the bat
See ya
It's so true though
It's so true they're educators
They got no money
She's gonna bat you
I mean like
Apparently she already did
In her youth
I mean in my youth
Can I get some more meat?
My meat permission slip
Give me the meat
Yeah extra meat baby
Teachers don't get paid enough
You survived getting the bat?
Yeah
I'm gonna visit the barber shop
And cry a little
Oh no
That for the occasion I
Think about taking some of that sighting off my hand son
It's sad to see
To see that you know it's just a chart
The beef was well done too
Problem is both was burnt so bad
And the flesh all crisp
And distorted limbs melded
You couldn't tell them apart
And well I didn't want to take a chance
On eating Italian
No sir I didn't
You didn't want it? You were gonna eat him?
Nice to see you again Steve
You're gonna eat him?
I can't talk now son
I guess you heard
That dang edged pastorelli
Went out and got his self-electric cheated
Somebody stole the barber's pole
The alarm system triggered the sprinkler
There was water on the floor this morning
And the derm crook left exposed wires out
The pastorelli came in
Flipped the switch and then
ZAP
Maybe them aliens is hot for colored glass after all
Any time Steve
Not gonna lie
I'm a little sad
Pastorelli
He didn't talk much
But he was there
Okay now I gotta figure out how to burn that damn building now
Sorry son
I hear you've been spreading all sorts of gossip about me around town
Did I?
That was a lot
A hot town huh?
Don't forget this
I don't think I told anyone about you by the way
That was some whiplash for sure
Mood switch crazy
Sometimes my mood switch gets like that too
You still love me though right Senpai?
Was this game developed by Swarri?
I don't know
Hello Steve
Those PTA busybodies have hurt my business
Something terrible this week
Nobody's buying my cookies
They're all saving up for the big bake sale
Somebody stole the barber's pole from that nice Italian
Italian
Can you imagine?
And then they left wife wires dangling in a puddle
Which Pastorelli immediately stepped in and fried
The stupid dago
Heavens to Betsy when it rains it pours
My bad
Once again
What can I say other than
My bad
Tee hee
Hello
I feel sad
I feel like I'm responsible for my actions
But I'm still gonna do it
Give me a glue
I'm afraid that's not good enough
What do you want?
You want some meat?
What do I show on the hotel ledger?
Why should I
You want some meat?
Why should I care about that?
That's your favorite thing
Meat
Why doesn't he care about the meat?
You want an autograph?
I don't know man I want a blackmail this guy
Oh blackmail this guy
Oh my gosh
Oh my god thank you for the
For the memba
I
I don't know I feel like I'm gonna get arrested again
I wanna I wanna dig
I wanna dig
I wanna dig for
Come on can I take the headstone?
What if I
No not the note maybe if I use the
Hotel ledger
How do I blackmail this man?
Can we give the meat to your father-in-law?
Oh yeah I could do that
Let's go see
If I can get some meat
That didn't work
It's not as bad as some
Point and clicks for example
And um
Sherlock Holmes
Um
No that can't be used for anything
No that can't be used for any
Can't be used for anything
Or use the ballonin
I have too many witnesses
You want meat?
Say that's
That's a nice cut there Steve
Did you bring it for me?
Sure
Sure you can have it
I'm gonna go get some meat again
This freak I know right
Why he just cares about the meat so much
Anyway I'm gonna go get some more meat
You literally can just give it to him
Okay that's interesting
Okay
Wait
Wait wait wait wait
Where's my meat?
Where's my meat permission slip?
Man that was a two times
Meat
Bye
What if I go to my dad and be like
I need more meat privileges
What if I go back home
And be like can I get some more meat privileges
Dad
Meat
What if I look at this
Kinky
Love equipment
Marve
What's going on in there
Erotic kinky
No leave that there
Go
No
Okay hold on
Go
Okay
I'm going
No
No not the meat
We can't get any more meat
That sucks
Okay well
I want the glue
How do I blackmail this man's
Our meat it's okay
The door it's locked
Young man we really
I do hope you'll attend the bakes
Sure
Ditch makes a poor resting place
You make it sound like I have
A choice that is rapidly vanished
Murder
I can't spell murder
Murderer
Oh shit
Okay bye
Where is he
No more meat
Murderer
Fire station
Are they still fighting
Well it's quiet now
Maybe they all killed each other
Unfortunately
Kettle
Looks like we've got us a many
Crime wave on our hands
Just got a report about another
Act of vandalism
Maybe related to the tucker
And the fire station robbery
Someone broke into pastorelli's
Barbershop and took his pole
Next morning pastorelli touched
Some live electrical wires that were
Left dangling and zap
No more barber
What was just an act of vandalism
Has just become a case of manslaughter
Harvest used to be such a nice
Little town
Yeah
Stop on by any time Steve
Let me check
I don't think I still have it
Notes
Sheriff's checkbook
Fire
Um
No I got the hotel ledger
Here anymore
Man
That's not pertinent to any investigations
Why does everyone think I'm talking about them
I didn't do nothing
A button
I only showed the button to
Oh wait
I showed it to the lost woman
Aw man she snitched on me
Did she snitch on me
Dang
Was woman
How dare you
Snitch on me
Sorry Steve
So pastorelli's barber pole
Got stolen
Big deal
Now me I know tragedy
Of course
I don't know
It's just a tragedy
Of course
Pastorelli got electricuted
But at least his pain is over
Okay
Why now
Lost woman
How dare you
I talked to you once
a triviality oh gosh the fact that she said a triviality makes me so go guess
he's not wrong pastoral rally isn't in isn't in pain anymore nobody's gone now
nobody can have nice haircuts no one
can I look at this
church I've been here before no one has a nice haircut in this town I think he
was getting much work of all means and take the ledger from the morgue on this
one this one oh can I look at it wait I can arm in his arm this wrench oh my
gosh look I can't I can hold another weapon
wow I didn't know that was a weapon I'm gonna unarm myself now you've had a
weapon this whole time I didn't realize I did strange how there's a correlation
between the bums who've died and the bums you've put up at your hotel
neither am I but I can tell you the odds against that
a curious thing to do snooping around old ledgers you're an odd and resourceful
young fellow
welcome welcome hi hi oh my gosh it means here too
wow there's everyone's here whoa welcome to the stream everyone welcome hi
everyone I'm playing an old point-and-click game from 1996 called
Harvester which is a very controversial game yeah it's like they're all
came here for me but yeah welcome everyone welcome welcome welcome I'm so
happy that you're all here let's now we're gonna confront him let's cut to the
shit let's cut the shit you're the murderer aren't you how little you
understand us us a slip of the tongue we are discussing my alleged pension for
murder tell me why would I kill these people only to bury them at a loss I'll
ask the questions for the sheriff will be sure and tell Dwayne Dwayne hello for
oh you're in you can't have I was only indeed security I'm a young man we you
know I seem to have misplaced a ledger I don't think how strange except mr.
Potsdam I can't imagine what else could have happened to it perhaps the dead
walk again and they're hungry for literature at any rate should any of
them show those ledgers around they'll wish they'd stayed in their graves bye I'd
say it's been a oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah I'm gonna go to the I'm
gonna go to the sheriff and I'm gonna see what that's about or maybe I want
actually let's save
Senpai
wait oh well Senpai Senpai
let's go in let's go in let's go in no not there
sheriff sheriff sheriff where the fuck is he
I'm sorry everybody's so darn happy about that darn big sale
mrs. Loomis will be there but the sheriff always says I'm half baked so I reckon I got no business
going okay bye any time kiddo his voice is so creepy where's the sheriff now I wanted to
show him my ledgers
I can't talk goodbye
any time kiddo okay okay this is the power of pointing clicks what do we do now
I want that glue I want that glue real badly and I want to blackmail this man
the sheriff always disappears but I need him we must be missing an item you must be missing an item
can we look at the live wiring no
do I give him the ledger
wait I'm gonna photocopy it I'm gonna photocopy it I'm a photo photo photo photo photocopy it
okay
wow mercy you're so smart okay god damn it that didn't work come on
well that didn't work okay
but you're you're so smart I should have been smart I should have been working I should I should have worked
I should have worked I was so smart for that I was so smart
oh man I could have copied it
I want to I want to dig up dig up a grave I'm gonna dig up a grave
oh man can we look at the ledger again well that didn't work
mercy did you just try to apply logic to a 90s point and click game
yes I could have photocopied it and then given it back and then he would have been like
uh-huh thanks for taking it back and I'm like you can't copy his biatch
you know I could have I gotta wave it in front of his filthy face
it should have worked
should I should I simply should I give it back or should I be like
no
okay we'll save again we'll save again we'll save again maybe try to kill me oh
oops that's the wrong one how do I go back no that's not the one I wanted to save and
that's the one I wanted to save and yeah that one
he seemed pretty mad about it being stolen
is he gonna kill me again is he gonna kill me again
young man I'd say it's been
hold on hotel ledger strange how I'm not not you may be right
there's for knowledge and other things then you intend to leverage this
nominally engaging coincidence for personal gain yes what an immoral thing to do Stephen
I'm not the one up to my ass in dead bodies yes but you have an un-reasoning faith in the
consistency of the universe things can change young man I want you to live here or in the
sheriff's office be sure until Dwayne Dwayne hello for me hello you can't have that I was only
indeed and have you anything I could hold security I'm afraid can I give you your ding ledgers back
strange I'm not not hey you
me
how little you understand us us the slip of the tongue I'll ask you
you can't have his in sick
what are you gonna do with the glue call hi I'm gonna glue his ass
I'm gonna glue his butthole shut
now I'm just like oh man where is he much to think about
no he's not here is he in here no he's not in there either maybe they're at the school now
to do the the charity charity um drive
yeah closet
in fact the actor playing the main character is currently in jail for crimes oh
okay
found a guy you want to know how to get the glue sort of
what crimes there was no crimes we've all hit it we don't talk about that we don't talk about
that thank you mods
kind of a chapel
I don't do crimes crimes that's not me okay I thought there was nothing there
oh what the
oh there's like a dead person here
am I am I supposed to do that
something on top of the lectern
oh
yeah what is the whip sound in there
oh man
can I take a closer look
oh I could try taking a picture right that's a good idea
damn it oh man
why is there whip sounds you're right why are there lips
let me check out the photo where's the photo
hmm
what do I do with this information do I show it to him will we take it back
so
we take it back some pie we go to the the sheriff for this
sheriff's never here
look we blackmail in this house always and forever I didn't even know there was a body in
there thank you some pie well let's save in case we we mess up
in case we mess up
look at this
ah you've taken up photography I see now why on earth would you choose such a grotesque subject
that John Doe you've got boxed up in the chapel he didn't just drop dead someone helped him take the
plunge hmm you may be right I'm a mortician not a medical examiner you don't have to be to know
that being ripped to shreds can be detrimental to your health this is not something you want to
be looking into young man
okay what should we say number one or number two some pie no shit I just want to find out who I
am get the hell out of here or is that a threat I've got the goods on you not vice versa
number one number one no shit that's what we all want what do you mean that's a game we win or
lose together wait what are you gonna tell me what I want to know or do I go to the sheriff
with these pictures that would be a grave mistake I assure you I've told you all I can
my losses have been substantial of late so I can't offer you money
the only thing I can give you an exchange for the photographs is my tube of astro glue I do
suggest you take it for it's all you'll get from me here we go should we just take the glue now
yeah we're just oh it's a trade or should I say not good enough I'm going to the sheriff
I'll probably die
fuck it I want to see be sure and tell actually I want the young man it seems like that corpse in
the chapel I'll dress up and nowhere to go god knows by putting these people up at the wayward
hotel I do orps the corpse reclining in the chapel right now is a prime example of the difficulties
I've just like oh that's where the hint came from he died a purely natural car but why come to harvest
to die I've often puzzled this was this was the hint oops though I can assure you young man that
nothing untoward is happening in harvest on the contrary it's an indication of our compassion
that I put up hobos in the wayward hotel and the order of the harvest moon mandates their prompt
burial even when they are without family or means and when it entails losses on my part
bye okay that was the hint say it's been a that was a hint he why didn't you tell me that before
anyways give me this again ah you that john hmm you don't this is
that's what we would get a look that would be I do suggest okay I'll take the glue wise decision
when a wasp's nest is stirred up it is seldom the wasps who grieve later thanks for the glue get
out of here I got a little things at our order but we got there we got the glue
now what do I do with the glue I wanted it so badly I wanted it so badly but now I'm just like well
what do I do with it wasp like the wasp lady yeah
yeah
I really wanted to oh wait I can't talk okay bye
we still have the bake sale today right and we need to burn the place down right
can't talk now
nope we still have the bake sale
bake sale bake sale where is the bake sale it's at school
no
seeing you here again what my breast just swells with when I went to get my head and worse
drop in again
adult quality time
see what we have our inventory we have the hotel ledger
mortuary ledger astral glue
damn it damn it damn it damn it
what can we do about the burnt flyer if I show the burnt flyer to him
that interests me not at all young man okay
where do I go next
maybe back home
I don't want to sleep it's the baby hello
okay don't forget to put the pin
okay okay we gotta figure out how to burn that place down
let's talk to the wasp lady yeah he did say about the wasp nest right
what if I show her the glue
it's not often
you want you want some glue
I have okay never mind
um geez why do
I get fire
okay first off we need something as a fire starter
oh wait the but maybe you could use the glue on the people
that sounds logical and therefore it probably won't work but that does sound
logical and maybe we'll be in for a surprise let's go see
let's go see let's go see if we can do it
where's my astral glue okay well that didn't work
no did you have a gas can yeah I gave it back though
I uh I gave it back though I gave it back so that the other man can start arson
arson logic fails again
can I grab this can
give me it give me it oh I want it I want that can of gas
okay we need something for the fire maybe maybe gonna ask the post office man
you know a lot about fire right wait is that a present in the background uh you know a lot
about fire right yeah my button funny thing that what are you implying
got the crap and what if I did I guess I'd be pretty grateful to anyone who could help get me off
the hook how you seem like a capable lad hypothetically let's say there was a gas can sitting
in the evidence room at the sheriff's office a gas can which might have some oh and Steve
okay sure um I already did that though like way at the beginning of the game
um burn flyer that interests me
I take it you can't take take the can nope
I got the barbershop can I grab the the wires does he have another one I don't think so but
I feel like that was a that was a dialogue that was meant for the beginning of the game
and here it is okay blah blah
yeah of course your final assignment is to set up
all right yes I suggest okay okay how do I get a fire
anything new in the general store oh there could be something new in the general store
no there is nothing new in the general store
how do I start a fire I want is there anyone with matches maybe I can get a match in a blowtorch
who would have a pair of matches
oh azzera azzera azzera azzera
welcome azzera
welcome azzera and raiders welcome to the stream
hello everyone I'm right now playing harvester
which is a 1990 uh
sixth game that's very controversial welcome welcome welcome everyone hi hi welcome to the
stream is is is azzera already going gone slips is it spooky it's a little spooky
but more like a parody than anything
oh welcome everyone I'm so glad everyone's here I'm trying to find something to start a fire with
is this a game about farming no
yeah it's more creepy and spooky can I get no matches have you gone to the bake sale yet
the bake sale hasn't started yet can I grab anything here
now
the bake sale hasn't started yet unless it already did
yin memario school it hasn't started yet it should be here but it hasn't started yet
see the bake sale will be held here but I haven't gotten it yet so I guess I'm going to have to
find a pair of matches but where am I going to get matches from
maybe the bake sale will happen at night
y'all got matches around
um does the store sell some the store doesn't have anything
so
would would the general lady have one okay I'll ask her you got any lighters
no doesn't look like it
maybe
what if I ask him about fire
sorry son no fire don't mumble son
dang it next time you put I just want something like a match or maybe a candle
you talked to Stephanie since you had to reload the game again I think so
if it isn't my fate
okay this goat lady is hiding to bed good night scissor lady good night goat lady
I think I talked to her I'm glad to see you yep I did come back and visit maybe I can snoop in her
her room I think she would have already started a fire I think she would have already started a fire
let's try
let's try yeah let's try the fire station you guys got any fires around here
no no they're not
the station of fire
thank you we need to figure out what to do with the glue I just wanted it
I really wanted it I really wanted the glue and I got it
and now I'm just like what I do with I know it's important but I don't know what it is
I've earned the glue I've earned it now I can feed some pies
now some pies don't have to just eat crayons
you don't have matches right now I don't think I have matches
I think he just meant don't kick the horn his nose
getting the glue was it's supposed to trigger the transition to the evening
it didn't
have we talked to everyone in town
I think I need matches okay where did where do I get matches
check the cemetery okay
where do I find matches the buried
no
hot stem family crypt
right
acts it open okay no
shovel it open well that didn't work
can I pry it open with the screwdriver
in a in a grave
okay
okay well it looks like there was someone on the ground in the last screen
over here
wait no
the leaning sycamore is dead rotten unstable for climbing or stringing nooses
do I
damn it
since harvester stream is a thing would you consider playing mystery of druids maybe
uh
I
thought I would be able to get in maybe if I can
hello
oh wow
oh
hold on hold on hold on I got this I got this
wait
oh
fuck you yeah fuck
heck is this no where to go
oh
take a picture of the empty grave what am I supposed to be here
maybe something was supposed to be in here
yeah we break all the windows
no
vandalism
am I supposed to be I guess I was just doing things I was like oh well maybe I can
okay well nothing's in there
oh
screams of mercy thank you for the two dollars he the key
the mattress should be on the ground in the screen where you dug up the girl
senpai we have a problem
there's something near the bench right here
oh I can't see the bottom of the screen no I can't
wait hold on I gotta move move the window up more
oh
the aspect ratio isn't exactly good to me where is it hold on
okay I gotta look at my look at my hold on let me look at my um let me look at my stream
okay yeah give me that give me open
it worked
so that's why you couldn't see it yeah I couldn't see it sorry sorry senpai
the aspect ratio on my screen is much different than what you'll see senpai
I tried to put this into full screen but I wouldn't put into full screen my bad
oopsie daisies mystery song yay now we have something to burn the place down
nightfall descends upon harvest we got it
now it's time to commit arson I feel bad terrible even
I thought the bake sale was tonight
oh
I should put this away buy some cookies it's for a good cause
I'll look alike
mercy what a terrible thing to say oh my gosh I got called out yes terrible
oh
mercy me hello Steve
exactly is this bake sale supposed to be a derelicts and bums who are wandering the town
we don't have enough money for a decent burial they deserve to be buried it's the christian thing
to do that's awful nice of you but why do so many derelicts and bums die in harvest
don't be such a wise apple Steve okay so that's a little creepy not gonna lie
not gonna lie that's a little creepy what a good boy you are
exactly is this bake sale supposed to benefit why I never isn't that right ladies yes never
what a good
mercy what a yes
genasium rules no blood on the floor do unto others as you would do unto your mother
no laughing no sports allowed okay
hey
mission the exit doors are locked from the outside
did I miss why are they locked
buy some cookies
oh wait wait wait wait
there's an open window well that didn't work wrong one well that didn't work damn it
can I grab ladder ladder window
oh can't well that well that didn't well that didn't work man well that didn't work man
we gotta get out of here I gotta we gotta get out of here I've got a building to burn
well that didn't work can I bonk the people
hello
are you able to click the cookies
mercy yeah
no like I can only talk what a good boy
what yeah
yeah
hold on
am I trapped maybe there's a second screen
oh wait
what okay we got it we got it
okay kind of creepy not gonna lie to you let's break into Edna's diner
use the axe
okay fine tape
first we have to save we have to save right Senpai Senpai
I feel it we are almost at the end
what's the tape supposed to do
can't stop the noise
it feels so bad not really
oh one major deterrent to the art of arson is to make sure no fire alarms are functional
we got it thank goodness I saved before
this is your first arrest Steve you just remember we've got a three strikes your
out rule here in harvest but you keep your nose clean yeah it makes it to the next day
which means I look he gives you a good night kiss too
okay hold on I'm gonna load the game again
okay how do we get rid of the fire alarm
how do I get
well that didn't work no
do I smash it okay okay we see the fire alarm
uh break it oh man no
okay the wrench well that did well that didn't work okay um
the glue dammit
look around a bit more Steve I'm gonna whip your back
okay
maybe cutting cables or something
okay okay
smoke alarm I don't get rid of the smoke alarm
is a chair
is this where we're using the tampon
dammit
well that didn't work
can you go behind the counter now as she's gone
no
well that didn't work well that didn't work
well that didn't work
grease fryer's on
how do I get that dang smart smoke alarm
do I tape it up
well that didn't work dammit oh man
when I get him on the counter or something
yeah I was gonna do the ladder but okay well that didn't work dammit
see it doesn't work didn't work
can I get him to walk over here for a second so I can take a look take cover
dammit
well that didn't work what I do with this cake cover
okay anything else
flowers
okay maybe cake cover
oh man dammit or maybe we can
take this well that didn't work ladder didn't work oh man blue man well that didn't work
they combine things again we just go like this you know like we
dammit just put it on top of each other
pie the glue to the rim of the cake cover
ah we did it
and now
get out of here
but
but Edna's diner blaze your task is complete you carefully make your way home to avoid any possible
witnesses
arson
arson I feel terrible but it has to do it we have to do it
whoa
we have to do it I feel terrible it's okay
oh Edna wasn't in there and that's apparently she lives outside of the diner
I don't think they're
yeah the two innocent people in town why are they like it's so interesting that they're the like
voice of reason and we are corrupted
I can't believe this man sleeps in jeans senpai you don't sleep in jeans right
right
okay first let's save save
don't sleep in jeans
do you sleep on with jeans on no I don't sleep with any pants on
I sleep in a big t-shirt but on cold days I wear fleece pajamas
fleece jammy lammies
I don't sleep with jeans on no I don't sleep with any pants on
I sleep in a big t-shirt but on cold days I wear fleece pajamas
fleece jammy lammies
what is it now Hank what why are you sitting in front of that blank tv
someone burnt down the tv channel there's nothing wrong nothing wrong honestly Hank
you're acting like an alcoholic I told you all that tv would hurt you
watching tv don't hurt me mom but not watching tv hurts bad if I find out who burnt down the tv
station I'll make him wish he was one of those damn Indians
uh I still want to hit my brother
Hank come on right mom how did the bake sale go
hello dear how are you today the nerve of some people burning down the tv station to detract from
our bake sale I doubt the perpetrator did it just to annoy the harvest pta coincidence I don't think
so just six months ago the newspaper building went up in smoke obviously there's a fire bug on the
either that or a communist communist huh I'm so scared
why are you so why are you scared now that the bake sales over I just don't know how I'll
fill my time oh I feel so useless what's wrong with her
oh it's not as bad as it looks you just pop them back in
see as good as new that tarantula she ate must have had wasp eggs in it
don't you think we should get her to a doctor what for she's got her mother how silly I was
feeling useless just because there are no more cookies to bake I can still rear my brood this is
a sign Steve I have a purpose again glad to see you're feeling better mine that fire still burns
my bridges first the newspaper building then DNA's diner then WHAR I sense a pattern and any
pattern I can't make a dress out of is no darn good I suppose you heard about DNA's diner burning
down sheriff Dwayne thinks it was a grease fire we took a black eye on the bake sale but I'm sure
the harvest pta annual blood drive will be more successful overall we made about 200 dollars
hardly enough to bury a dead horse and definitely not enough to cover the annual blood drive
the blood drive
oh is my sister okay annual blood drive huh if you knew how much blood we get you'd be more impressed
donations are mandatory Steve if you're still here come sunday you'll be expected to give
until it hurts I suppose until it hurts even Hank will have to donate of course lodge members
are exempt remember that hey either way no one's sticking me with the needle we don't use needles
what the hell do you use hank that kid over by the television your little brother is homesick
from school is he real look at the show he's watching wouldn't you say he's I don't know
I don't know don't you dare you okay bye don't forget my sister okay she's fine I think hello
don't forget
what are they use well that didn't work well that didn't work
well jimmy here's your paper again you've been doing a swell drop putting the paper out in the
morning you just keep doing that and we won't have any problems that's not much to ask is it
okay no
do I go to the Potsdam's residence first
did you say hello to your father for me yeah I did thank god harvest will never be the same
without DNA's diner without DNA for that matter what
I can't walk close to the kid why not go upstairs and talk to Stephanie she'd enjoy the company
and while you're upstairs feel free to vlog sorry Steve I'm too upset to talk right now
I can't believe anyone would burn down the tv station the night of the bake sale
I just hope nothing will stop the harvest blood drive and I don't think that anything can
I'm not one to gossip but I'm sure you've heard that DNA's diner burned down but did you know
she killed herself when she found out what her and her daughter too what I hear the sheriff suspects
the fire was set if you ask me whoever burned down the diner is a murderer just the same as
if he'd blown Edna's brains out personally
I feel so bad Edna the voice of reason
hmm
what have I done
how could I do such a thing
oh well oh well we gotta finish the game let's go let's go
we gotta just kill the launch people let's go
whoa I burned it down what are you gonna do huh can I can I tell her this
we're too in deep now we gotta keep going
thank you for your honesty Steve that shows character go ahead and help yourself to refreshments
while I call the sheriff you're gonna turn me in of course dear confessing to a crime show's honesty
as well as stupidity one thing we don't need more of
hello sheriff Mrs. Potsdam here Steve took Stephanie's bones yes he's right here
the sheriff says hello Steve he'll be coming by to pick you up
now tell me Dwayne how have you been
I didn't say
it's okay it's okay it's okay we'll just go through the text and stuff again
oh back to the electric chair we go somebody help me
nah let's go I got it don't worry senpai we can do this again don't sleep in jeans
oh wait the electric chair we get the electric chair if we kill someone
what is
watch on it watch button if I
like good fine on gosh my brother I hate him
hello then I doubt
this guy he doesn't gonna do anything jump out now that the big sales over
my
let's get this that tarantula don't you think what for
mine that first the new my sense of pattern I suppose you heard about DNA we took a black
eye on the big six overall we made about two annual blood drive if you until until hey we
don't
watch what what's hard this blah blah blah okay I'll go look for it
hi don't forget there we go what's the town always is messed up yep you don't want to
watch that again oh did you want to watch it senpai my you've gotten such a grotesque hobby already
good
no wait I was only kidding oh oh I thought you finally got
got got a got a sense for the taste for like you know orbit stuff
things are so much better between us when you remember oh did Steve not go crazy you
don't think we're already crazy see you later alligator see you later alligator
just saying
oh I wouldn't pop anyone's eyes out yet right just be good senpai just be good
did you say hello to your no it's harvest will never or without DNA for that matter
eat and a stop mum okay never mind hi
why not go upstairs and sorry Steve I'm not one to her and her I hear the sheriff suspects the
fire was set is that a little harsh not at all she wouldn't have killed herself if not the fire
no all in all someone murdered her and I hope he's happy thanks for the guilt trip damn
we're so jaded now yeah
yeah yeah I know I know I know I know I know I know but we have to keep going we have to keep going senpai
oh okay no beeping allowed again okay it's filled wait does that mean it's filled
she's gonna be so mad she's gonna be so mad at me
it's okay we did what had to be done I'm glad to see you I feel so alone cooped up in here
I saw the tv station go up from my window it lighted up the whole town
looked like hell I wished it would consume the whole damn place and me with it don't talk like that
I'm sorry I just can't stand it anymore I wish there was something I could do
there he is make love to me
um well what should we say uh okay okay sure okay if you sure you want me to
now
so
it's fine it's fine it's fine nothing's showing nothing's showing nothing's showing
nothing's showing nothing's showing
who's behind the people again mr. potstown
what the hell is that
I'm glad to see I heard that why are you looking at me like that did you torch it stave
do I say it do I say it do I say it do I say it no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no no me no me no
curse not how can you say such a thing
best up okay
jesus edna hung herself and your daughter too
and no idea that would happen I'm sorry stave what's happening to you I don't know
you're just trying to get to the bottom of all this no matter the price right
you're right you're right this has gone too far
well what do I say what do I say oh no morality gotta get out of here
we're into deep
probably too do you mean it yeah I'm ashamed of the things I've done then you'll stop the
initiation process yeah
bye come back and visit me soon okay
by the way did I mention I'm a liar
let's go to the lodge
DNA's diner is no oh that hurts
I've always been such a kid her
as soon as she realized what had happened to her beloved establishment
a true entrepreneur and a credit to our nation
you bastards you made me a murderer
her suicide was an unforeseen by-product predictable by no one she killed herself
she made our choice if you were a catalyst join the rest of the world we all live
of the deaths of others still you sought to torture diner and to which
candidate I thought I was initiation this was only a trial to determine your worthiness for
testing your initiation into the mysteries of the harvest will soon begin what in the meantime
be patient protocols must be observed before initiation you think you got a
sore throw from that I think probably took a lot to break you will know when you receive the
invitation bring it here and your initiation shall begin
what do you mean it took forever to get here
what is this two different things
still you sought to torture
regardless having completed the trials an invitation shall be forthcoming
meantime how are you let me see if I can put on the bat
can I I can't even go close to him
that is unfair that's cheating
wow I can't get close to him
I can't get close to him save all right let's go to I want to go to the tv station
save game
don't sleep in jeans senpai he's immune I know he's immune thank you
artist for being a member
say can you spare a dime for a buckaroo who's down on his luck oh my gosh the whole shebang
just went up in flames and I'm looking to mosey on to greener pastures where the sun sets
always golden and there's always another savage to kill oh my gosh his face is completely
well can I break in
well that didn't work well that didn't work man
well I'm surprised he's he survived yeah me too geez
okay scene
I've tried so hard to find an excuse to keep on fighting
I care and I can't go on alone any longer this diner he loved us was all we had
was always a struggle to keep it running in such a small town
and now we've lost it I know that I can't afford to support this now there's only one way out
I'm sure you won't be able to understand the depth of despair that would enable mother to
put a rope around a baby's neck and push him into the air and jump after her
and when your father makes me know if she kicks around and takes a long time to strangle
else for you I won't cut her down I've got to be stronger than I ever was before
but I hope she doesn't get it
God help us and forgive us
oh they're showing it huh
is is that the sheriff
who cooked his food
I feel so bad
now he has no place to eat
I'm sorry I get a tan
seeing you here again when it rains it pours isn't that so first Edna goes through all that with
her daughter then she loses her diner if that happened to me I'd hang myself
drop in again
they're really they're really really pushing it oh it hurts it hurts
thank you he's a total issue for the member
they're like I was like okay don't feel bad don't feel bad we had we had to do
one must be done and now they're making me feel bad
like everyone else they're like oh they deserved it Edna though no she never deserved any of that
why do you like that
think about taking some of that siding off my hand son I'll cut you a nice price on it
the tv station burning downs being good for business lots of folks are thinking of investing
and I murdered her yeah
nice to see you again Steve I can't talk now son I'm busy with this game
ain't that a kick in the head first we lose the only barber in town in poop no more diner either
why don't they beat all and now that the tv station's burning down maybe folks will get off
their duff and get outdoors maybe take up alien hunting say clown will aluminum siding protect
you from them alien censor jobbies nope you show up on their radar as a hunter surrounded by
aluminum siding trust me leads to take just my luck anytime Steve
oh at least they didn't twist the knife over and over again
sorry son no time to talk neither rain nor sleep nor snow nor hell shall keep the mail from its
appointed rounds hello there young man what's the good word someone burned WHAR down last night
really I hadn't heard anything about it and since I don't have a tv I didn't notice it was off really
fire don't mumble
son WHAR don't mumble son hey bye next time you put
oh at least he's happy about it
didn't say anything about Edna though
about the general store
hello Steve I don't mind telling you when I heard what happened to the diner I went out and got me
extra insurance right away I have no desire to wind up dangling from my rafters like Edna
believe you me Steve did you see the fire as I was watching the tv station go up
I was reminded of the old Sentinel building when you think about it you know two communication
complexes going up in smoke you have to wonder if it was a coincidence
hello Steve well I bought everything from her
yeah well she bought extra insurance
I guess we can check what happens with
oh can I not oh wait I can't visit her anything you got to say it's not okay bye
well I guess the wasp lady's okay she's fine well let's see what this guy says oh we hate this guy
sorry Steve too tired to talk right now I just gave the Tucker a tune up I'll talk to you later
DNA's diner burned down what a shame women running things that's the problem if she'd
had a man around that fire never would have happened what a waste damn terrible thing that business
with the tv station I can't sleep now we hate some waking up in a cold sweat
I'm thinking of getting some fireproof aluminum siding for my garage we hate some that's a good
I hate some
uh we'll probably get killed if we spread smash his car but goodness that I smash it
hmm I don't like that I don't like it no Sherry that woman was the voice of reason
that one was the voice of reason
nah and now it's a real one young man we real
the WHAR fire is just another example of the vagaries of my profession
odd after such a catastrophic conflagration not to have any fatalities disappointing in a way
I might have gotten some paying customers for a change
okay so nobody died
nobody died surprising
is he still gonna talk again
we
bye
no I don't need to go to the cemetery there's nobody in the cemetery
fire station can I go into the fire station now nope looks like I can't
please station
wait wasn't that the guy at the morgue how does he do be a receptionist at the same time
magic game logic
what about game memorial
seeing you here again oh did I already talk to him
Stephen I'm glad that discipline ah Stephen you're just in time I was about to administer a
lesson in good citizenship to these youngsters I'm sure one of these precious darlings burnt
down the television station and they if the little shits could talk I'm sure I'd find out who but as it is
I guess everyone will have to take my special civics course again
okay bye stop by anytime Stephen okay bye
oops
why can't they talk they said they look zombified maybe they sold sold their mouse
shots or anything
hi nothing
nothing
heat plant
tv station
say what happened the whole shebang
I give him his thing say what happened no
where are the meat coming from highly likely cats it's highly likely cats
um
I talked to everyone
maybe I'll give my brother a memento
maybe he wants it now
oh shut the fuck up
did you go to the missile base should I talk to the missile
I'd be holding a bat because I equipped him with a bat
no sleeping jeans
can I use the ladder to get the yellow thing off the roof the the frisbee
potentially oh man probably not talk to my dad again
what
hi hi dad
hi dad um
did I talk all right I was supposed to talk to the guy right
I'm gonna happen to dad when a man and a woman are very much in love
they bring out the scaffolds the barbed wires etc and one day you're gonna have to learn about it too
halt who goes there it's just me steve what do you want did the llamas send you
no the llamas they hear me
what should I say
thank god for that your next assignment is to infiltrate the lodge before it's too late
get it at all costs mister oh god help us all
hi remember duck and cover
I think if you say they're pink he sets off the nukes I figured
I figured he would I was like I set off the nukes once I can't do it again anything else
the guy's got access to nukes yep he's got access to nukes and therefore
how do I get the sign
is this it do I like just I'm done
check your mailbox oh yeah there could be a mailbox oh yeah there is a mailbox
nope nothing
we talked to Stephanie I did talk to Stephanie
what good gosh she's such a brat even without tv let's go check out Stephanie
I just sleep I think this game makes you go to sleep
oh what happened
what the fuck happened
what do you mean your dad must have pulled some strings be sure and check Stephanie's pillow
you lucky bum what the hell are you talking about you'll see once the sheriff gets here
huh Stephanie Stephanie things will never be the same now
yes I'll be watching tv nights what the heck what okay you can come in now son
she she dead
god is that what I think it is yep it's a spinal cord is it Stephanie
I can see a resemblance but I can't be sure more pie sheriff pie don't you realize what's happened
oh indeed I do I can just hear the tongue waging at the pta
was it suicide
never heard of anyone pulling their own spinal cord out before off the record I'd have to say nope
no all in all I'd say this was dead by natural causes natural causes natural causes
you can't live without a spinal cord son nothing unnatural about that
think I will have some more pie
right away I can't believe this well I guess he has a point believe me you get to the point
to where this is routine
now the only clue we got is that card on her pillow take a look at it
I can't fucking read that be it known that the sacred order of the
practically confession confession to watch son murder isn't that what you're here to investigate
son you don't investigate natural deaths no point then I'll get to the bottom of this myself
yeah I'm sure you will
more pie sheriff
don't mind if I do
all right let's take a look at that card again
I guess we got the lodge invitation
hello Steve have some pie
there's skeleton in the family closet
we're going to put her in the crypt keeping bodies in the house
it's just not sanitary I see I don't suppose it'd hurt for you to take the card
seeing as it was addressed to you
the shucks
senpai senpai
but that's my job so I wonder if there's more pie
thank you boy for the 420 tip
a lot of senpais died in natural causes
oh it happens you know
it just happens when and senpai's being a little oh shh low guy
we got the invitation in the end at what cost
I'm so hungry Steve so hungry
if I'd been an astronaut I could afford all the meat I want the red kind
and the young pink kind too
pink kind
okay they said family crypt right well I guess we're going there again
here we go
oh
I'm only full of cannibals yeah here we go again
oh right in time my rash is starting to act up damn it there we go
no I thought that was the hint
okay
I I pre-booked I thought I thought she would be yours or there was a hint about that
is your arm any better now
well it's slightly I might have to go get the ice pack again what does the note say
hold on
I'll go back to my house to look at the note
where is the note there it is
be it known that the sacred order of the harvest moon hereby extends notice of the eligibility
of Steve Mason her niche initiation into the sacred mysteries of the harvest let me
presented with all the possible haste to sergeant and arms for
for commencement of the rites
okay I wish my rash would leave me alone too
if we have to meet him now
what do you want from me
you received the invitation but you have not brought it
what do you mean brought what I don't understand the invitation was not the card
but the spinal cord it must be presented to me I have to get the spinal cord
you to enter
you expect me to steal their mains and bring them here you stick bastard
he wants the freaking spine
you were provided an invitation bring me the skull and spinal cord if you would pass to the
world beyond okay I don't understand what's the other one I you were provided and okay okay
well I go back now I guess
looks like I go back
if this is this a metaphor to grow a spine probably
well I already grave robbed so we're fine
here we go
back at it again we already did this I did this way earlier that's so funny
that's so funny that I already did this I did things out of order
okay get over here
it says reference to sub zero's fatality oh yeah that makes sense
here you go you stinking bitch
ah you have done well now let the initiation commence as your mystic
mystic ag
requested and required that I turn over this sacred dagger to you to aid you in your quest
what is this what the heck you just gave me the logo
you must now enter the lodge initiates find it our style place are you supposed to help me
or get me killed I'm starting you on the path of initiation to a very special very exclusive
brotherhood I am merely the administrator of a test whether you view me as an enemy
or a friend depends on how well you're prepared to pass this thing you haven't said what it is
it is a special weapon using it will be part of the initiation
the hell with your initiation
okay whatever occurs in here is relevant to the great question which you cannot help but answer
what is at issue is whether in answering the question you will find the answers you seek
you will encounter those intent on preventing or prompting your answer depending on how you
look at it while the assumption is you want to live dying is easy and provides its own answer
but not for you just tell me is Stephanie dead or being held within the membership director
on the second level keeps track of such wow you just talked a lot then you are against me
I am the sergeant at arms I am here to ensure that the protocols are observed
deviation from a protocol shall result in punishment remember what I have told you
now let the initiation begin yeah making him deliver that much exposition with that with
that voice is a lot not again the third disc
it worked the first time give me a second save and give me another second some pie I'm gonna have to
my arm itchy I'm gonna have to get the um oh what's the word
congrats on completing the tutorial Kohai thank you I need to ice my arm again
I need to ice my arm again okay
okay I'll BRB some pie
okay okay some pie I have the ice pack on me so my my hands my arm movement is very limited
so we're gonna try anyways let's see how this goes
hopefully it calms down for the night I normally I would I think I would take some
Benadryl but I don't want to get sleepy because I want to see if uh if if I can finish this
oh you're here excellent you'll find them through that door excuse me you are the exterminator
are you not no in that case I'm afraid you'll have a hard time of it sir
recently the lodge has become infested by pests they need exterminating or
you were a part of the lodge this whole time they need killing and plenty
that's the quickest way to the second level the second floor sir the entrance is hidden
but a little reflection should reveal the answer to find the key to the second floor
reach deep within yourself I wish you good luck sir I only hope you can stomach what's ahead
okay
bust of George Washington glares down at you in silent reboot
bust of Barbara Bush glares down at you Benjamin Franklin glares down at you
in silent rebel Thomas Jefferson Beethoven pretty sure that was Beethoven
hold on let me see my inventory
all my items are gone I guess that's the only thing I have where is it
where's the way
a display light huh
you
Sam hi we're going to the butthole we're about to be pooped out
we're about to be pooped out by all covered lining envelops the room
oh
it contracts
a nauseous pool of acid covered by a nutrient film
oh
okay we're good a shallow lodge deep in the porous walls it looks like a koon of some
sort like kill it
a tomb and tom sent mushrooms soaked in buttle bile
there's two exits where do I go
a save
but hole
the non pulsating one the hole hole is a hole
get here get get get get get get get get get die die die die die die
a
plop oop all oops it was unnaturally
two ways to grow with erupting from his prison
and I can't cut anything it looks like
am I back at the beginning again
yeah it looks like I just went around in a circle okay let's go down through the hole
back back back gross eyeball got the walls out of yours
gross gross gross anything around here
that was my accident
upon leaving the strange rooms behind you notice a burning feeling in your skin
you also notice a gooey film of slime covers your clothes
a totem mystic figurine mysterious and impressive clearly made
clearly made in china says so on the bottom
cracked vase oh a real plant
oh this is a cloakroom sir by definition not a fitting place to seek answers
however it's plain that the acid from your ordeal is eating away at your clothing and skin
I can clean your clothes for a minor consideration of five dollars I just change it
I don't have five dollars
servingly as you step over the rug you spy a brand mark seared into the fur
where a dozen books on animal husbandry bound in leather and authored by very
prius leading third rike scientists or eyes of this mutated cow blink in this
disinterested lee listening in the fire life this initiation process is so
thank you me sack of s for the 10 the 10 tip the initiation is pretty freaky
right five dollars I just got monetized I really did
what am I supposed to do blazing fire a good old radio
wow battle music and on this table still warm
all right we got battle music time
oh wait be gone be gone
wait why am I shit
shit
oh let's go through the butthole again
great okay
what the hell
what the hell why am I keep on clicking why is it
okay
can I do that again I didn't like what I did I'm gonna do that again
I'm gonna do that again I didn't like what I did
okay there we go there I feel better now
this is a cloakroom sir by definition not a fitting place to seek answers
however it's plain that the acid from your ideal is eating away at your clothing and skin
I can clean your clothes for a minor consideration of five dollars I don't have five dollars
is that any place where I can get five dollars or do I just you know
you acquired a shotgun
it's only two shells fuck it just give me the blade
all myself
huh
can I wear the toga can I put it on me okay
five dollars okay
I can't wear the toga abe abe okay why not
so
that changing room I think so was I allowed to change into it
mutated cattle rhubarb
then murder are illegal in this game technically wait he's gone
where did it go
okay we're good
it must have disagreed with something that ate them
I got in the five dollars here
far stocked with only domestic beers you'll pay for the acid that's eating through your clothes
how the hell am I supposed to wear it then okay
okay well I can't I wear it
is that normal guys
huh
death by a lack of five dollars how am I supposed to get five dollars
where do I get five dollar reduce
so
well I hope you're proud of yourself killing my clientele
ever since the monsters invaded this level the members have taken to dining with the grand
pubab stairs wait is this the meat guy the last few meals haven't been up to snow the problem
is the freshness of the corpses or lack thereof see the supply has dried up the sergeant at arms
always used to insist that bodies killed in the lodge be disposed of without trays
and so the members would bring me their business for preparation and dissemination
behind on this killing dear you're not a member are you you're an initiate forgive me I can't say
another word about it can you tell me anything that might help me not really not really huh I hope
ever since actually the sergeant is you know garner stephanie you need to talk to the membership
director up on two cannot I take this meat well I hope you ever act the sir
sorry can you not wait where did the meat go I take oh I took the meat yeah
okay we're good
oh well I'm gonna grab that too I'm gonna grab that too
severed head never boils well I'm gonna get just go now
something was in those vents
oh wait no that's the way
do I lead it with meat you want some meat well that didn't work well that didn't work
you want a chunk of meat well that didn't work damn it okay
never mind
I tried my best
I'm the best scene be skipped because I want to this is a cloak I dollars
huh
well I ever since the monsters invaded this one actually I have to admit my life the sergeant
it oh can you tell not
uh ever since actually the sergeant wait are the hands twitching they're twitching
you need can you tell me not okay give me this give me give me that
me the give me that thanks let's get out of here
okay uh cash register right is there a cash register can I hit it it's locked
chicago
the cash register is locked
okay
was there something in the last supper maybe
you
walls
pain
mountains which barter escape from harvest is divisible through thick glass
I don't have five dollars though
must eat something bad must eat something bad
wonder if the saloon area must be a famous painting too oh hello
what's this
is that me
oh am I fighting myself
so
no
wait what was that hold on this is bar key no I got it I think I have the key to the bar which
means I can open this right yes can I take that one too yes thank you
yes we got it we got it oh we got to say before finding a plant yeah you're right
I just had to be an alcoholic
this is a cloakroom
here take five dollars
can I talk
okay well he took the acid off my clothes now what
this is your last warning
oh
I don't get the toga okay
that's nice I didn't get the toga
okay here's the five dollars
thanks I guess I'll see you
now we have to figure out how to deal with that plant
my kid is gone I have to kill him to get his gun
okay save here can't you just kill him though I can but the door is locked
door
what happens if you give him the hundred dollars I don't
want do I have a hundred dollars 200 dollars
okay does he like sandwiches do you like sandwiches well that didn't work okay
damn it I think this plant well that didn't work oh man we'll eat food
Percy's rich I wish I was rich well that didn't work then I can provide mama
and mama and papa some stuff that they rightfully deserve
well that didn't work you know what I'm gonna go to the guy and see if he would take the two to
honey you're right
did he just take it no he didn't do anything anything else no he's just silent
he's just silent
dang it now we have the plant
Beezer's full of stuff well I hope you've ever since the
mom actually I have to admit my last few meals haven't been up to snow I think the problem is
I think papa dropped something or lack there are see the supply is right the sorry can you tell
me not really how do I kill
how do I kill this plant
like seriously how do I kill this plant
nope
a shotgun
I need it from the call room
is there a liquid poison us enough do I need the shotgun I don't want to kill this man if I don't
have to
say beforehand
door
door door
is there anything in the bougie looking room oh yeah
this one right blazing fire
you think I can like use a torch or something wait candle can I get a candle or a torch
oh
oh man let me pick it up let me pick it up
maybe like even a little little stick or something
hmm I guess I can use the fire on the the guy
that I'm blinking for I howl head in the wall oh yep oh yep curious
ten pie give me a hint
a shotgun seems handy I really have to kill him huh oh man goodbye mr. doorman
oh well thanks
I see no other way oh well
well now that I have to kill everyone
well I guess I have to kill everyone oh I can eat the sandwich
oh now I'm all better
okay
can I use the shotgun on it
oh shit oh fuck oh shit fuck
where was I supposed
okay
murder was for nothing no it's for something don't worry
maybe if I offer him the sandwich no
I'm curious about the plotted planted plant
like
here this one
there once a beautiful fountain need to garner the weeds have taken over
oh the one with the doorman oh okay I don't know
I really need that shotgun
no dead babies okay
oh I can take this
okay well maybe I can use that
wait is there something around here that I can use
a glass I can fill the glass up with something
I don't know what but I can
you
you killed Ed now why are you so against a random man for his gun
listen that was an accident this one's more on purpose
you want me to go out
like back back here I don't think I can leave I don't think I can leave
it was not murder Mercy wants to know what the cloak is for like the toga
sure why not this is probably the part where it's so weird that you have to buy a hint book
right
okay
wait wait wait I have to actually kill this man okay
give me a second I'll just kill him bye
take toga
all right
Scythe oh nice Scythe
what's that over there rare gem shotgun shells oh thanks
I could use more of that I guess how are you supposed to I didn't know how I was supposed
to figure that out though
give me a second I'll just equip this then yeah
yeah
no seriously however was that was that the part where they're like oh well um
I don't know that was that where they were selling hints hints
buy the hint book for an extra 99 okay wait wait wait wait Senpai Senpais when
you were young did you ever buy hint books
no no too broke too broke you'd you did wow how was it I've never I never bought
a hint book what the fuck is a hint book well back in the day when you when you were stuck
in a part in a part of a game you would you know call in
okay we're gonna save here you would call in
you would call in or you would buy a hint book
and in order to help you and a lot of games purposely made it really obtuse
was was really obtuse to uh to get was there something in the the hint room
oh no was that something in the the room hold on
is there a light switch in here sorry I can't tell was there a light switch
all marks
sorry I don't see anything
I switch in the cloak room oh this
this
oh
It crashed!
Is it not going to appear again?
Oh no, it's not capturing!
Senpai is not capturing right now!
I think I'll take this as a sign, Senpai.
I'll take this as a sign to stop right now.
I think this is the sign.
It's going to just catten.
Wow, Senpai! It looks like we're going to have to return to this game another day.
I'm pretty sure we're very close to the end, so it'll probably be the game and then probably another game if I finish earlier.
But oh man, did it crash!
It's okay, I'm so happy to have all my Senpais here with me.
So let's check my schedule.
Okie dokie.
Tomorrow is my day off.
Tomorrow is my day off and then I will have my karaoke on Sunday.
And then I'll post my upcoming schedule around Sunday, probably.
Yes, most likely.
So I hope, oh man, I feel bad that we haven't finished the game, but hey, it crashed!
What else are we going to do?
Thank you for the 420 almighty hair on!
When a lovely Senpai you are.
I'm excited for karaoke, but I'm also a little nervous, so I hope Senpai doesn't mind if I'm not the greatest singer, but I'm trying!
And that's the idol way, right?
I'll be, I'll be, I'll be your, your arrow idol.
In training! Well, maybe I am already an idol.
Oh well.
It's the hardest I count, so I'm going to try my best.
I'll try my best for Senpai.
What exactly is an arrow idol?
Well, if you take away the A, what does it say?
Senpai, figure it out!
Good job Senpai, I'm proud of you!
Remember, use your brains, and your eyes.
Your eyes and your brain.
It's okay Senpai.
We got, we have to, we have to be a little sneaky here.
We have to be a little sneaky here.
It's okay, I forgive you.
That's asking a lot, Kohai. No it's not!
Heck, I'll even, I'll even put in some books into the cages so you'll read.
Like a Moby Dick, or a Skylight Letter, or a Picture of Dorian Gray.
You can have a lot of books to read and then your mind will open.
Or I'll open your mind myself using an axe.
Can we get some Hamlets? Sure.
How about the Mysterious Island?
I've got, what book do I have?
Hold on, Senpai, I have a book about an island just for you.
The Island of Dr. Moro. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Island of Dr. Moro. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, where's Waddle? Where's Waddle? Where's Waddle? Where's Waddle? It's too easy.
Can we read Cardcaptor Sakura instead?
Did you even watch Cardcaptor Sakura?
Speaking of, speaking of Senpai.
Did you do your homework yet?
We still have time. Of course you have time.
I just wanted to make sure earlier you start the Moro free time you have.
This class has homework?
Yep. I can explain. Yeah, about that.
Well, I'm going to expect my thousand word essay. It's very, I'm being very lenient.
And your thousand word essay do by, I think I said, I said in three weeks, right?
So that means this is week one. No, this would be week two.
You have one more week.
Wait, what's the essay on? Cardcaptor Sakura?
Cardcaptor Sakura. Everyone needs to watch.
Everyone needs to watch Cardcaptor Sakura in the two movies.
Where do we post it?
I'll post it on my Twitter and then everyone can reply underneath.
Does it matter how it's written? I'll take MLA citation.
What about clear card? Clear card is unnecessary. That's only bonus material.
That's bonus material. You don't have to do that. It's only if you really want to.
I'll take MLA citation or APA.
Make sure to alphabetize it.
Google docs. Not Google.
Not Google. You have to send it in.
Actually, better yet. Marles. I'll give you a grade.
If you send it through Marles, I'll give you a grade on it.
What's our reward? You want some motivation?
What's more motivating than a job well done?
In a little phrase. Heck, I'll tell you I'm proud of you.
Does Marle have a max word count? I think it's a thousand, which is what I'm saying.
I'll make it 500. 500 word. How about that? 500 word essay.
The card after your localization is okay. Yeah, localization is okay too.
I think Marle is exactly a thousand. I was going to say a thousand characters. It'll be fine.
You have to write about how much you liked it and how great Sakura is and what you think about the series.
I want you to learn from it. There you go. I mean so nice.
I would just torture everyone and be like, you have to watch it in these days and if you don't.
Well, I guess there's a free vacancy in the cage.
Honestly. Honestly, I just think it's just fun.
I think it'll be fun if I can talk to my senpai about something that I really love.
I actually really like the Novana one. Novana? Is that the company? I like the Novana dub. That's the one I grew up with.
So I want something in common with senpai and what's better way to connect our hearts than through anime.
Can I write about how much I love Mercy? You can do that as bonus work.
I think it'll be fun though. I think all of us watching something together would be really fun.
And so I can gap about it and everyone will be like, oh okay, I get it. I understand.
The one from the early 2000s? Yes, that one.
Do we have to do our sources? No, but it's just fun to mess with you.
I'm not going to do a watch along on YouTube simply because, wow.
I'm getting in trouble. I'm getting bonked. I'm getting a little spanky.
I get a little spanky. So I don't want to do that. I don't want to get in trouble.
I worked really hard. I worked really hard senpai to not get bonked by YouTube.
So I worked really hard. I've even been like, I hope I don't get in trouble for uncensoring now.
But now that I've got monetization, then they can take it away at any point.
Thank you, boy, for your $1 tip. Congrats on 5,140 subscribers.
We can celebrate karaoke, right? Do I have 5K already? Thank you.
Thank you, everyone, for your support then. I really appreciate that.
My next big goal will be 10K. What do you think?
Had you been censored on your model this whole time? Oh, yep.
Will you be able to do song requests on your street on Sunday?
I don't think so, mostly because I practice these songs.
10K sounds easy. I don't know. That sounds kind of hard.
Do you have a favorite Sakura outfit? I love the cat outfit and I love the prince outfit as well.
I think those are really cute.
You could do 10K without even trying? Really?
I don't know. That seems really hard.
I mean, I would be super happy if we reached 10K, but do you need to watch the movies too?
Yes, of course. That's how the series ends. It's within the movies. That's how it ends.
It's really nice. Also, the first movie is really nice and the second movie is really nice too. I think they're really good.
It's possible. Let's hope.
My biggest goal is going to be 100K, so Mama Mercy can be like,
Oh, look, you got a play button. That's nice.
But you remember us when you get famous? Of course. I always remember all my supplies.
Is there a manga too or does anime and movies cover it all? The anime and movie pretty much cover it all.
Actually, the anime has more stuff than the manga.
Will you name the button after your parents if you can put anything on it? I think I'll just put myself on it.
I'll get a bigger cage if we get 100K. I'll get a bigger cage for everyone.
I think if I can order more than one, I think I'd like to give the allure one, strong one, and then get my own.
I think I'll keep it as my channel title as a memento of it.
You can order more, but it does cost. I'm willing to pay for the cost of it.
I'm willing to pay for the cost of it.
Or getting one to me as well.
I really want one. Mama's been trying to give me suggestions on how to get to 100K really fast and she was like,
Sweetie, you should do a film tour of the Costco. People are always interested in watching Costco.
Yeah, Costco's vlog.
I don't think I can show a tour of the local Costco because I think that would dox me hard.
But I admit, I'm pretty sure there's a lot of people who are very interested in Costco.
Costco dream date. Cost effective and free samples.
Show off the Costco rotisserie chicken. Yeah, actually those are pretty good.
I've never seen one, so I just did. You can pass the laptops.
ASMRRP concept virtual Costco tour.
I think my favorite, you stalk images and pretend I'm taking you through Costco.
Oh, that'll be so funny. Okay, I'll see when I can do some pie.
Imagine if Costco sponsors us. That's not going to happen. We're definitely not family friendly.
Are there VR chat? I don't think I have a model for or I don't even have like a regular model.
Costco's family friendly?
Well, yeah.
I think so. Yeah.
Anyways.
Oh, I'm getting a little, little, I'm getting the little eye burns.
So I'm going to guess that I'm getting really, really tired.
He's a placeholder model.
I'm getting really tired. So I'm looking forward to tomorrow being my day off and then I can hang out with some friends if I wanted to or just rest the entire day.
Who knows?
Mercy, your mouth is the most expressive I've ever seen. Excuse me.
I think it's because I'm an expressive person.
I think it's because I'm an expressive person. Otherwise, otherwise, I think it would be pretty much the same as any of my other gen mites.
But yeah, I'll take a good slaps.
But yeah, I look forward to seeing my supplies on Sunday. I may need breaks if, for example, you know, once again, my arm decides to flare up and be, be, be bad.
So yeah, I hope everyone has a good one. Okay.
And I'll see you again next time.
Speaking for Mercy! Bye!
Thanks for watching!